Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Big Brain!
Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Lets start!
Das war's für heute.
Lets go guys!
So Leute, da bin ich ja am Start, ein Fan hat gesagt, dankeschön, excellent Subscription,
Massive IQ Subs hier wieder, ich hab grad gefuttert, guck, dass ich nicht zu müde
werde jetzt, eh. So, also, ihr habt's wahrscheinlich nicht mitbekommen, aber gestern Abend beziehungsweise
heute, irgendwann, von gestern auf heute, glaub ich, kam das neue Windows April Update
raus. Also ich mein, wir haben fast Juni, ich weiß, ja, es ist auch das Mai Update, was
04 heißt, aber Microsoft ist ja mit ihren Benamungen schon komplett wirr, ja. Also die
ursprüngliche Versionierung bei Windows war ja mal Jahr, Monat. Also aktuelle Windows
Update 20.04 bedeutet 2020 04, das ist April. April ist nicht Mai und schon gar nicht Juni,
aber es heißt Mai Update, obwohl 04 April ist. Man weiß es nicht. Microsoft Logik ist
eh, was Benamung angeht, nicht zu durchschauen. Deswegen gehen wir einfach mal von aus, sie
wissen, was sie machen oder auch nicht. Ähm, was sagst du zum 8GB Raspberry Pi 4 und 64
Bit Raspbian? Das mit dem 64 Bit Raspbian hab ich gar nicht mitgekriegt. Müssen wir
jetzt wirklich jetzt den Edge aufmachen, um uns das anzugucken? Nee, müssen wir nicht.
Wir gucken das jetzt mit Edge an, Alter. Alter, was sind das alles für komische Leute? Ich
will von denen gar nichts wissen. 64 Bit Raspbian gibt's das. Aber die gehen auch auf
mit allen anderen Raspberry Pies. Also zumindest auf dem 3er auch, ja. Und es gibt schon eine
Weile eine 64 Bit Raspbian Variante. Aber das mit dem 8, mit dem 8, 8GB hab ich gelesen.
Und da muss ich ehrlich sagen, ich weiß nicht wofür. Das hab ich heute auch gelesen, aber
ich weiß nicht wofür. Ich hab legit keine Ahnung wofür man das genau braucht. Eeeh,
ich hab kein Adblock. Singles in Bruchköbel, schaut ihr an, wer bei Parship ist. Ja, excellent,
schreibt mal her. Outbrain.com. Ah ja klar, die wartet nur darauf, dass ich 1. Platz Testsieger
Partnervermittlung. Excellent, also. Ich bin, Moment. Chat, so geht es aber nicht. Was
mach ich denn jetzt? Das geht aber nicht. Okay, also. Dann bin ich heute mal kein Hubschrauber,
sondern ich bin ein Kerl. Ich suche, ah das geht, okay. Immerhin, immerhin, das geht.
Das geht auch? Excellent. Kostenlos anmelden? Nee. Warum? Ich will die Werbung eigentlich
gar nicht sehen. So, eigentlich wollte ich mir das hier angucken, weil einer mich gefragt
hat, ob ich schon gesehen hab. Und ich frage mich, wofür man, also mehr RAM ist nie verkehrt.
Das ist Chromium Edge. Angeblich ist Chromium Edge jetzt Default. Ist das Chromium Edge?
Woran erkennt man, ob das Chromium Edge ist? Am Logo? Aber angeblich ist doch Chromium
Edge jetzt. Guckt mal hier. Hier. Chrom. Wo steht's hier? Chrom? Hier. Ah. Wann Microsoft
den neuen Edge in das System integriert wurde, bislang noch nicht. Ach so, ich hab mich verlesen,
Leute. Ich hab mich verlesen. Ich dachte, das ist eine Liste, was alles neu ist und
da steht Microsoft Edge Chromium. Das ist ein typischer Fall von... Naja, was heißt
lesen müsste man können. Guckt mal, alles ist hier neu. Alles ist hier neu und hier
steht Chromium Edge. Ich mein, anhand der Überschrift ist schon ganz schön, ganz schön
gebaitet, dass es das jetzt nicht ist. Naja, zumindest, mehr RAM ist nie verkehrt, aber
ich bin beim Raspberry Pi ehrlich gesagt noch nie, wirklich noch nie an RAM-Limits gestoßen,
sondern eher an CPU-Limits oder IO-Limits. Also RAM, also weiß ich nicht, vor allem was
soll denn der kosten? Was soll denn der kosten? Steht das hier irgendwo dabei? Blablabla. Also
ich hab hier eine Version mit 4GB, das reicht dicke. Ähm. Koste? 80? Wo steht's denn?
Ah hier. Ähm. 80 Euro gut, 20 mehr als die 4. Ja, kann man machen. Kann man machen,
ich denke die 20 Euro Aufpreis sind schon gerechtfertigt, aber die Musik ist ein bisschen lauter. What
the fuck, MonkaS Musik vor allem gerade. Rare Parod. Ähm. Also 20 Euro sind schon gerechtfertigt
für 4GB, mehr Arbeit, Speicher, das ist okay. Hm. Aber, also ich hab jetzt wirklich wenig
Verwendungszweck für. Für was bräuchtet ihr einen Raspberry Pi mit 8GB? Ehrlich, sag mal
Leute, vielleicht fällt euch ja irgendwas ein. Bei mir fällt nix, mir fällt nix an.
Bist du nicht dieser geile Max FPS? Ne, weiß ich nicht, wer das sein soll. RAMDISK ONLY,
IN MEMORYDB. Ja, mir fallen auch Anwendungszwecke ein, Konstruierte, wo das was bringt, aber
auf dem Raspberry Pi. Minecraft, okay. Ja, okay. Minecraft, ohne Scheiß, das lass ich
mir gefallen. Wenn einer einen Minecraft Server laufen hat, dass der, der, also vor allem
die Java-Variante und die wird man also im größten Teil verwenden, die braucht halt
nun mal RAM ohne Ende. Ja, das ist richtig. Aber ansonsten fällt mir ehrlich gesagt nicht,
sonderlich viel ein. Jetzt hab ich noch neue Updates. Vorhin schon mal gecheckt, aber man
weiß ja nie. Siehste, Leute, habt ihr's gesehen? Eben stand noch da, Updates, alles aktuell
und jetzt lädt er neue Sachen drunter. Das ist Windows Gebated, einer an allen Ecken
und Enden, wo es nur geht. Windows 7 Wallpaper, na wenigstens einer hat's erkannt. Hat jemand
von euch gestern Abend den SpaceX Raketen Lounge geguckt? Oder besser gesagt wollte
gucken. Da hab ich, da kam ich mir auch Gebated vorne. Ich bin extra, ich bin extra off. Wir
haben noch ein bisschen Warzone gespielt, bin extra off und hab dann, hab mich rüber
an Fernsehen noch mal gesetzt. Ich mein, für irgendwas muss ich ja mein Fernseher mal benutzen.
Hab den Channel aufgemacht und ich hab dann erst nach 20 Minuten kapiert, dass die gerade
nicht die Rakete betanken, sondern enttanken. Und dann hab ich festgestellt, ah okay, top.
Abgesagt. SpaceX Lounge Saturday. Wie viel Uhr im Samstag? Schreibt das irgendwo? 21.33,
okay das ist natürlich besser. 22.33 war das letzte. Stunde früher. Hier, 21.22,
deutscher Zeit nachgeholt werden. Nice. Wollen wir uns das zusammen angucken Chat? Ich mein,
von der Uhrzeit her geht das. Besser gesagt darf man das überhaupt Restreamen? Darf man
das Restreamen? Is it okay to Restream a Rocket Lounge? Ja. No it's not. Ja es ist die Frage
ob SpaceX das erlaubt. Ah die NASA hat die NASA erlaubt, das ist doch bestimmt. NASA
hat eine Twitch-Team, dann gucken wir uns das zusammen an. Ich schreibe mir das mal
in den Kalender, dass ich das nicht vergesse. Also wann? Samstag 21.22, ja da mach ich schon
ein bisschen vorher an. Raketenstart anschauen, easy. Das haben so viele gemacht, okay ich
hab nicht geguckt, ich hab nämlich nur den offiziellen Stream geguckt. Okay geupdatet
haben wir, wir starten mal neu, es ist immerhin Windows, hallo ich hab geklickt, es ist immerhin
Windows, wir sollten das mal neu starten, da weiß man nie so genau. Ist euch mal aufgefallen
wie modern das Cockpit aussah? Wisst ihr noch so die Cockpits die man so kennt, die
schreien ja 1970. Ich mein der ganze Kram ist ja von auch 1970. Und das SpaceX Cockpit
mit Touchscreen und runden Formen und Raumanzügen irgendwie auch nach 2020 aussehen. Richtig
mit Touchscreen ja. Ob Touchscreen so gut ist bin ich mir ja nicht sicher, aber ich
gehe mal davon aus, dass die wissen was sie machen. Tanzer du weißt doch genau wie es
funktioniert. Aber ich weiß nicht ob Touchscreen im Eifer des Gefechts wirklich so sinnvoll
ist, Knöpfe haben seinen Vorteil. Ach ist das so Patrik, ich hab mir das nicht eingeguckt,
weil es würde mich wundern, Touchscreen ist halt, ich stell mir das halt gerade mal vor,
wenn wirklich was schief geht oder irgendwie ein bisschen angespannte Situation ist und
mal angenommen der hat dann auch kein Handschuh an oder so und erstmal so einen schön verschwitzten
Finger an der Touchscreen geht nicht oder drückt Knöpfe die er nicht drücken soll
und sowas. Allein wie viele Fehler im Frontend, dass das ist das SpaceX Frontend ist bestimmt
Electron Chrome. Chrome Electron ist das. SpaceX Frontend, das sah so modern aus. Ist
der neue Edge nicht dabei? Ich dachte bis eben das es ist, aber anscheinend ist das
nicht. Alter wer sind diese Leute alle? Ich kenn die gar nicht. Gut den hab ich schon
mal gesehen, den Typ hab ich auch schon mal gesehen. Weiß nicht wer das ist, wer ist
das? Ich kenn die alle nicht. Hoffentlich nicht an Corona. Alter was für scheiß News, wer
will denn sowas sehen? Egal, zu damit. Windows 10 gab es schon 2004. Hier kannst du mal selber
sehen wie die Astronauten zur ESS fliegen. Okay, zeig mal her. Ups, ich wollt mir das
Wow, so sieht es ja überhaupt nicht aus, aber okay. Äh, naja.
Ja, exzellent.
Das ist zu advanced, ja ich sehs schon.
Oh, es bewegt sich. Leute es bewegt sich. Exzellent.
Und jetzt? Ja, das ist echt zu advanced für mich.
First try, easy.
Easy, first try, Leute, first try.
Kann ein bisschen Gas geben. Hier kann man bremsen. Ich hab ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung
was ich überhaupt mache. Was ist das? Keine Ahnung, irgendwas von SpaceX, wo man andocken
kann. Kann man Gas geben? Ist das Gas geben, was ich hier mache? Genau, starsetzt.
Es ruckelt ganz schön, ich hoffe im Weltall ruckelt es nicht so sehr.
Easy first try, Leute, ich sag's euch. Oh, Alter warum dreht sich das weg?
So geht das aber nicht. Ey, Raumstation, bleib da.
Ich hab keine Ahnung was ich mache. Ich hab beim besten Willen echt keinen Schimmer was
ich mache. Ich erkenne auch nicht mal was hier überhaupt.
Okay, first, vielleicht doch nicht first try. Was passiert denn wenn man, kann man sterben?
Kann man hier sterben? Ich flieg jetzt mal gegen das Ding dagegen.
Ich flieg jetzt mal gegen das Ding dagegen, mal gucken was passiert. Achtung, bam. Easy.
Okay, was auch immer, wir wollen uns die neue Windows Version angucken.
Okay, also, schauen wir uns mal an. Was gibt's Neues in Windows 10 2004? Das wohl
allerwichtigste Feature, was ich im Vorfeld gefunden hab, ist, man kann jetzt die Geschwindigkeit
von Updates begrenzen. Exzellent Hackerman Feature.
Das brauchen wir. Wo geht denn das? Das muss ich mir gleich mal angucken, wo das funktioniert.
Update. Advanced Update Options. Delivery Optimization. Advanced Options.
Mein Gott, ist das wieder versteckt, Alter. Ist das euer Ernst? Habt ihr gesehen, wie
versteckter Scheiß wieder ist? Hier, erste Mal musste, erste Mal musste auf Advanced Options,
dann landest du hier, da ist es nicht, dann musst du auf Delivery Optimization und da
ist es auch nicht und dann musst du noch mal auf Advanced Options und dann ist es da.
Meine Güte, ey, wer denkt sich das bei Microsoft aus, diese Menüführung? Massiver Painschamp.
Advanced Options in den Advanced Options, ja. Was hast du für eine VMP Software? Das ist
VMP Workstation. Okay, limit how much bandwidth is used for
downloading. Das ist ein ganz sinnvolles Feature. Doch, das ist tatsächlich ein ganz sinnvolles
Feature. Upload Settings. What? Ich lade Updates hoch. P2P Updates.
Ach, ist das, wenn ich andere Rechner in meinem Netzwerk auch aktualisiere oder so?
Was ein Schwachsinn. Na, okay, meinetwegen. Solange ich nicht ins Internet irgendwelche
Updates hoch lade nebenbei. So was wie Torrent, genau. Wir hatten eben einen, einen, einen,
wen hatten wir, wo ist er denn? TGA Philipp Twitch Prime, danke schön. Excellent Subscription.
Ich muss mal gerade nebenbei gucken, dass ich keine Subscribers übersehen habe. Streamlabs.
Doch, Clocks HD habe ich übersehen. Aja ja. Den Flynn hatte ich schon, aber Clocks HD
habe ich übersehen. Seine monatliche HiIQ Ladung abholen. Excellent.
Max, du musst auch Werbung für Twitch Prime machen. Ja, das muss ich erst machen, wenn
es passt. Das muss ich erst machen, wenn es passt. Das kann man nicht einfach so, man
kann nicht einfach so zwischendurch sagen, so nach dem Motto Leute, wenn ihr einen Twitch
Prime, das muss, das muss passend in den Content integriert sein. Dass die Leute quasi innerlich,
innerlich sagen Pains Champ, aber trotzdem Subscriber. So, also. Excellent. Okay, also
das ist wohl das neue größte, das Killer Feature von 2004, von 2004, was übrigens
die gleiche Versionsnummer hat, wie, falls euch das noch nicht aufgefallen ist, wie Ubuntu
sind wir auch gerade bei 2004 und das wird in Zukunft weiter so gehen. So, also das ist
wohl eines der neuen Features und die finde ich gar nicht schlecht. Ein weiteres neues
Feature, was ich schon gesehen habe, ist, wir gucken uns jetzt mehrere Artikel an und
gucken uns die Sachen nach und nach, nach und an. Also die Anmeldeoption juckt mich nicht,
ich benutze nach wie vor ein lokales Windows Konto mit Passwort. Insider, ne mag ich nicht,
verwende ich nie. Also ich könnte mir eine Windows Insider VM machen, ja, das könnten
wir machen, da könnten wir uns den Kram früher angucken, aber meinen normalen Rechner packe
ich nicht ins Insider Programm. Microsoft hat ja mit normalen Updates schon genug Probleme.
Ich könnte mir höchstens eine Insider VM machen. Also die Windows Anmeldeoption juckt
mich nicht, ich mach das oldschool mit Tastatur, äh mit Tastatur, ja mit Tastatur mach ich
das auch, mit Passport, Username, Passport lokal und gut ist. So, Merkfunktion für Anwendung,
Windows, im gleichen Menü kann man mit dem Schalter Apps neu starten und festhalten ob
sich Windows beim Ausloggen herunterfand, bloß, ey wo kann man das abschalten? Das geht
mir mega auf den Keks, dass Windows jedes Mal Programme von sich aus startet. Im gleichen
Menü, was ist das gleiche Menü? Inklusiv im gleichen Menü kann man auch Apps neu starten.
Ok, gucken wir mal was der hier findet, wenn ich Restart sage. Start Apps, ah Startup Apps,
ne das ist was anderes. Was Energieoption, ja. Ich mein man könnte es ja vielleicht über
die Suche finden, Restart. Restart Apps after signing in, ah exellent, da ist es doch. Windows
Hello Face, this option is currently unavailable, was ist das überhaupt? Ah, achso, Face sign
in, Fingerprint is unavailable, ja gut ich hab kein Fingerprint Scanner. Windows Hello
Pin, wo ist denn der Sinn davon? Jetzt legit wieder ernst gemeinte Frage, in dem Fall wieder
mal gar kein Windows Flame, warum soll ich ein Pin verwenden anstatt einfach ein Passwort?
Also, warum? Ich kann einfach ein Passwort eingeben oder ich kann Pin eingeben. Aus welchem
Grund soll ich ein Pin verwenden? Weil es geht, Kassensystem, ja ok, man könnte sagen
vielleicht für Rechner, für Rechner, wo man nur einen Numblock dran hat oder so, aber
ich mein man kann ja auch nur Zahlen als Passwort verwenden. Bei Pins spart man die Enter-Taste,
ok, ok, ok, das leuchtet ein. Security Key, was? Picture Password Swipe and tap your favorite
photo, what? Was ist das? Select Picture, ach excellent, das geht, das ist vielleicht
ein bisschen ein schwaches Passwort wenn ich nur ein Bild hab, oder? Was? Setup your gestures,
was? Remember, size, position and direction of your gestures, ok, Kreis oben links, ein
Strich von links nach rechts und unten, hallo ich wollte ein X machen, ok, ein Kreis oben
links, ein Strich unten und was hab ich oben gemacht? Ein Strich, ok, congratulations,
das muss ich jetzt ausprobieren, das muss ich jetzt echt ausprobieren. Und kann ich
jetzt, ach ich kann auf wenigstens passen, ok, Kreis oben links, ein Strich unten und
dann hier, ok, ok, ein Kreis oben links, ein Strich unten und ein Strich hier, was mach
ich denn falsch? Kreis, Strich, Strich, ah jetzt hat's funktioniert, excellent, ha,
yes, excellent, Geschwindigkeit ist auch wichtig, absoluter Knaller, sehe ich auch so, ok, nicht
Control Panel, Settings, Settings wollen wir, Restart Apps waren wir gerade, ok, Picture,
Passwort, ehrlich gesagt, naja, warum nicht, ja, es ist halt vorhanden, ja, ne, ok, was
haben wir sonst noch hier schönes? Require Sign In, na, das juckt mich nicht, Dynamic
Log, ne, off, genau, genau das will ich, genau das will ich, das macht es bei mir aber nicht,
unter meinem Windows hab ich das noch nicht, ich hab nämlich noch eine ältere Version,
New Start, ne, ich hab, ich hab die Option immer in anderen Windows noch nicht, ok, nice,
Pog, also nächstes, Autostart Programme, bla, bla, bla, bla, die Netzwerkübersicht
Unter Netzwerk und Internet-Status hat nun eine Anzeige für die Datennutzung der vergangenen 30 Tage, okay.
Mal gucken ob ich die finde.
Mal gucken ob ich das finde.
Netzwerk und Internet-Settings.
Ah hier.
From last 30 days. 180 MB. Data Usage.
System und Edge.
Limit.
Ich glaube das geht doch schon eine Weile, oder?
Ah, Wärmegrö und Mrit.
Mrit und Wärmegrö hat alles klar.
Okay, wie sieht das bei meinem System so aus? Bei meinem aktuellen System?
Äh, da?
Da?
Ah.
Nee, da geht das gar nicht.
Okay, excellent. Neues Feature.
Okay, wo war das jetzt nochmal?
Da?
Data Usage.
Äh, kannst du mal Windows-Taste plus machen für das Emoji Fenster?
Werden da bei dir jetzt kaum Mojis an?
Ja, müsste, müsste.
Hier irgendwo, ja hier guck.
Davon gibt es jetzt auch mehr.
Das habe ich ja auch unbedingt gebraucht.
Lenny-Face, was auch immer.
Das habe ich unbedingt gebraucht, dass ich nochmal kaum Mojis habe.
Echt, bei dir sind die nicht?
Ah ja gut, das ist wahrscheinlich verbugt, das ist ja öfters mal verbugt.
Wisst ihr was ich auch sehr merkwürdig finde?
Dass hier oben die Emojis in Farbe sind und hier unten sind die Emojis alle in Schwarz-Weiß. Warum?
Vielleicht kann UWP in diesem Control keine farbigen Emojis anzeigen.
Wir werden es nie erfahren.
Jetzt sind sie alle am tippen hier.
Ah, hier, huge.
Datadüse gibt es aber schon seit 1909, da ist es links in der Leiste.
Ich weiß gar nicht ob ich 1909 überhaupt schon habe.
Okay, also das war ein tolles neues Windows Feature. Was haben wir dann als nächstes?
Im Untermenü Zeit und Sprache, Sprache.
Ist eine Übersicht über die wichtigsten Spracheanstellungen zugekommen? Die zeigt Karel mit Infos zur Anzeigesprache.
Vielleicht ist es dann ein bisschen...
Ne, was suchen sie?
Zeit, Zeit, also muss ich Date, Time, Language. Hier, das muss ich suchen.
Ah ja, alles klar, was auch immer.
Der Unterschied ist dazwischen, aber okay.
Englisch.
Okay, da sehe ich jetzt keinen großen Unterschied, juckt mich aber auch nicht.
Vielleicht Datumformat hier, das würde ich eigentlich erwarten, dass das da steht. Ist auch egal.
Im Einstellungsmenü Geräte, Maus kann man nun endlich die Geschwindigkeit des Mauszeigers.
Ging das vorher nicht?
Wer konnte vorher keine Mausgeschwindigkeit einstellen?
Okay, das muss ich jetzt nochmal überprüfen. Maus.
Maus. Tatsächlich.
Ernsthaft? Was ist mit Microsoft los?
Eigentlich ist das gar nicht lustig. Eigentlich ist das eher so hier.
Ja, weil ich habe es bei mir auch eingestellt. Wo ging das hier? Pointers? Ja, genau.
Immer 6 von 10 oder was stellt man da standardmäßig ein? 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11 habe ich verzählt.
Immer 6 von 11, genau. Immer 6 von 11.
Okay, das wusste ich gar nicht, dass das nicht geht. Aber da sieht man aber wieder, wie beknackt das Ganze ist.
Ich meine, warum macht man ein neues Mausmenü und erlaubt in diesem Mausmenü nicht das banalste des banalen Settings für Mäuse?
Also immer, schauen wir uns mal das Neue an. Microsoft hat geklickt.
Hallo, Microsoft hat geklickt. Aber übrigens ein ganz tolles neues Feature ist die Web-Suche.
Die Web-Suche lässt sich nicht mehr ausschalten. Keine Möglichkeit mehr die Web-Suche zu deaktivieren.
Also wenn ihr keinen Bock habt, wenn ihr Max eingebt, mich da irgendwie auf YouTube oder so zu finden, keine Chance.
Man kann das nicht mehr deaktivieren. Tolles Feature, ja. Kann man nicht mehr deaktivieren.
Alter, ich habe hier eine Facebook-Seite, das habe ich schon ganz vergessen. So ein Kack verwende ich nie.
Man kann es in der Firewall blocken, ja klar. Das ging ja aber schon immer. Warum ist denn hier so ein Strich drunter?
Warum ist denn hier so ein Strich drunter? Checkt das irgendjemand?
Das lädt er gerade runter. Das soll er aber nicht runterladen. Ich will Farmhero Saga nicht haben.
Bloatware. Farmhero Pending. Uninstall. Candy Crush Friends. Uninstall. Cortana, das geht nicht. Rate and Review.
Okay, ist gut Microsoft dann. Cortana. Okay, probieren wir mal die neue Cortana-App kurz aus.
Hä? Moin, Joss. Also mir würde es ja schon reichen, wenn Cortana in Englisch available ist.
Das muss auch gar nicht in Englisch Germany available sein.
Kann man denn die Sprache wenigstens umstellen? Dass ich sagen kann, ja ich möchte die englische Variante verwenden.
Geht das? Gibt es hier irgendwelche Optionen in diesem Fenster zum umstellen?
Cortana. Core. Nee. Nee. Das Ding hat keine Option. Ich kann doch nicht mal sagen, ja dann lass mich halt Englisch verwenden.
But why?
Du kannst in welchem Settings Dialog? Ich sehe hier keinen Settings Dialog. Das Ding hat keinen Settings Dialog. Du meinst hier?
Ah, Speech. Aber Speech ist United Kingdom, das ist richtig.
Oh, ja. Remove. Okay, dann Removen wir Englisch Germany.
Ah, Remove. Wie? Nee.
Das will ich auf Deutsch haben. Sonst habe ich das dämliche englische Format und sowas. Das will ich schon so haben. Aber warum geht dann Cortana nach meinen Currency?
Hä?
Ja, in welchen Sprachen? Ist denn Cortana überhaupt? It's available.
Wisst ihr was wir jetzt machen? Was wir unter Windows einfach... Dann geht's. Dann geht's. Wir starten einfach neu. Englisch US. Genau, das ist das einzige was geht. Hell yeah.
Ja, ich möchte halt nicht Ounces und BTU und Gedöns als Einheiten verwenden oder Fahrenheit oder sonst was. Ounces ist ja meine Lieblingsgewichtsangabe.
Ja, wie viel wiegt die Maus? Ja, 84,5 Ounces. Du weißt doch kein Mensch, was das ist. Oder Fuß oder so ein Kram. Stone, Alter. Ja, genau. Und so Kack.
Könnte ich einfach normal. Deswegen, ich verwende immer als Language Setting, deutsches Tastatur layout, englische Sprache. Ob jetzt US oder UK ist mir egal. Und als Format und Currency verwende ich immer Germany.
Ok, mal gucken ob es jetzt funktioniert. Cortana. Ah, nö. Ok, wir machen jetzt mal den ultimativen Test. Wir stellen jetzt auf Kokona ein.
Englisch, Germany, Language, Afrikaans. Englisch, United States. Fuck yeah. Jaja, mach alles. Solange man Tastatur nicht umstellt ist alles ok.
So, dann gucken wir mal ob Cortana damit geht. America first.
So, das ist aber Highspeed.
Was? Ah, ich dachte der will dass ich ein Windows Account anlege.
Das ist schon mal ok. Microsoft Account anlege. Aber will er nicht, er wollte mich einfach nur abmelden. Ok, geht dann Cortana jetzt. Cortana.
Bless RNG. Hey, ah und jetzt muss ich mich einloggen.
For best experience. Ja, wenn man ehrlich ist, für ansonsten gibt es keine Experience. Leck mich.
Ich gebe es auf Leute, ich gebe es auf. Ich ignoriere das einfach. Das wird alles so sein wie sich das Microsoft gedacht hat.
Genau, wir wollten uns ja angucken dass man jetzt im Mausmenü endlich die Geschwindigkeit verändern kann.
Guckt euch das mal an. Microsoft hat es geschafft. Das wichtigste Maus. Moment. Och please.
Nicht dort andere Settings wie dort.
Muss das sein?
Please, warum ist das so schlecht?
Ok, wir stehen jetzt hier auf 6 von 11. Ok, was passiert dann wenn ich jetzt hier volle Pulle einstelle?
Ah, volle Pulle ist auch da, volle Pulle. Und 6 von 10 hier update aber da nicht. Aha, also 6 von 11 sind 10 von 20.
Naja, wenn man ein bisschen auf und ab rundet in Microsofts Rechnet dann kommt das sogar hin.
Das kommt, das kommt, also nein es kommt nicht hin aber es kommt noch am ehesten hin.
Es ist halt die Hälfte ungefähr. Was sollen sie machen? Ich mein die logischste Option wäre gewesen einfach hier auch 1 bis 11 zu machen.
Das wäre eigentlich die logischste Option gewesen.
Stimmt, wo ist eigentlich die Mausbeschleunigung? Das ist das allerwichtigste.
Ja, Enhanced Pointer Precision. Das ist die am schlechtesten benannteste Option in ganz History of Windows.
Enhanced Pointer Precision. In Wirklichkeit ist es genau das Gegenteil. Destroy Pointer Precision ist das.
Gibt es eigentlich noch den Kram? Den Effekt fand ich unter Windows 95 so geil hier. Guckts euch mal an hier.
Da kam ich mir voll toll vor als ich diesen Follow Maus Zeiger hatte.
Monarch S. Vor allem auf den alten, auf den alten LCDs.
War das tatsächlich ganz praktisch weil da hast du oftmals deine Maus nicht mehr gefunden.
Low FPS Effekt. Oh beim Thema Low FPS. Soll ich euch mal den neuen Monitor zeigen den ich bestellt hab?
Ich zeig euch mal den neuen Monitor. Ich hab mir nämlich den neuen Monitor bestellt.
Nämlich einen BenQ XL 2546S. Der ist jetzt ganz neu. Ist der rausgekommen?
Also den ohne S gibt es schon seit 2 Jahren oder so. Die Schwitzerkiste exakt.
Der ist vor 2 oder 3 Jahren ist der rausgekommen. Jetzt quasi seit diesem Monat gibt es einen neuen.
Der ist gerade nicht so wirklich lieferbar. Aber angeblich hat ihn Alternate die nächsten Tage wieder.
Oder auch ein paar andere haben ihn die nächsten Tage wieder.
Und ich hab mir den hier jetzt bestellt. Hier mit dem Griff zum wegschmeißen. Mit den Scheuklappen da.
Also es sind ja Focus Shields oder so nennen sie den Kram. Nur Full HD. Ja gut 240Hz dafür.
Muss man sich überlegen was einem mehr wert ist. Zumal man halt 1440p mit 240Hz wahrscheinlich selten schaffen wird.
Selbst mit einer guten Grafikkarte. Ist aber teuer. Ist das berechtigt?
Ja und ne. Wenn man sich die ganzen Features anguckt ist es relativ einzigartig und ziemlich gut.
Wenn man nicht wirklich haben will die Sachen dann ist es preisleistungsmäßig nicht so gut.
Aber es geht. Es ist wieder eher gesagt es geht. Also es gibt ja noch ein paar andere Modelle von anderen Herstellern.
Die sind teilweise ein bisschen günstiger. Teilweise ein bisschen teurer.
Man kann natürlich auch richtig hardcore die Sache machen und diesen 4K 144Hz holen für 1200€.
Oder was das Ding kostet da von ASUS ROG ASUS. Aber das ist eigentlich ganz gut. Das ist schon okay.
Also der Preis ist schon relativ teuer. Man kriegt günstigere 240Hz Monitore. Aber der hat ganz gute Features.
Mal gucken ob die das hier unten reinschreiben. Also für Gaming interessante Features.
Wofür das nichts ist wenn ihr jetzt sagen wir mal Bildbearbeitung, Videobearbeitung oder hauptsächlich in Desktop Anwendungen unterwegs seid.
Da findet ihr bessere Panels. Da findet ihr bessere Panels sowohl vom Blickwinkel her als auch vom Farbraum.
Von der Abdeckung her vom Farbraum. Da gibt es insgesamt günstigere und bessere Bildschirme.
Hast du dir die 20% gesichert? Ne? Wo? Wo steht da was von 20%?
Stand da eben auf der Linkseite echt? Ben Affleck genau.
Shopping. Du meinst hier? Wo stand da was von sichere dir 20%? Ist das GBAID? Ach direkt bei Alternate. Ah Moment ich habe das falsche aufgemacht.
Wo? Hier oben? Neu? Wo? Ich glaube ja.
Da war Links Werbe. Ach keine Ahnung scheiß drauf. Ach rauszoomen muss ich. Ach so. Ne das ist glaube ich irgendwas anderes.
Ah da ist wahrscheinlich auch nicht alles dabei. Und bereits im dargestellten Produktpreis enthalten. Ah ne ne ne dann GBAID.
Ne ne ne da ist es dann nicht dabei. Das muss ein Teil davon sein. Everyday Essentials was auch immer.
Zumindest was ich jetzt mal loswerden wollte. Also was gut ist. Also erstens ist man natürlich der Schnellste im Homeoffice mit dem Panel.
Also was an dem Monitor die Features sind warum ich ihn mir gekauft habe. Es gibt ja noch ein paar andere. Oder warum ich ihn mir bestellt habe.
Im Juni soll er zwar kommen. Mal gucken wann er ankommt. Also die Klappen jucken mich jetzt persönlich nicht so.
Ich zeige vielleicht mal die Bilder. Also die Klappen jucken mich nicht so. Wahrscheinlich werde ich die Klappen auch gar nicht montieren.
Das steht einem frei. Die werden mitgeliefert. Die kann man dran machen. Muss man aber nicht. Vielleicht probiere ich es mal aus.
So was ganz gut ist. Das hier ist ja relativ standard. Das Ding USB Ports, HTZ Anschluss und das ist relativ standard.
Was ich ganz cool finde ist das Feature zum Wiederaufbauen. Genau weil der Monitor hat überall an allen Sachen wo du Höhen und Winkel verstellen kannst.
Kannst du quasi so rote Markierungen machen. Da kannst du dir merken wie du ihn eingestellt hast.
Und nachdem ich auch mal ganz gerne ein bisschen Sachen auf meinem Schreibtisch rumrücke. Find ich ist das unglaublich praktisch.
Dass ich den Monitor innerhalb von 2 Minuten wieder exakt, auch wenn ich ihn vom Schreibtisch abgebaut habe, runtergestellt habe, wieder draufgestellt habe, den Monitor nach 2 Minuten exakt wieder in der gleichen Position habe wie früher.
Also ich bin da sehr allergisch wenn mein Monitor auch nur einen halben Zentimeter schief ist.
So was haben wir sonst noch dabei? Der Stand ist jetzt nicht so toll. Höhenverstellbar, seitlich verstellbar. Anschlüsse sind jetzt nicht so der Wahnsinn.
Man kriegt hier nochmal Headphone. Ne, weiß gar nicht ob das Headphone ist. Man kriegt ein DVI, ein Dual Dings Link, wie auch immer DVI falls man den auch braucht.
Man kriegt 2x HDMI, den braucht man aber auch nicht. Der einzig relevante Anschluss ist eigentlich ein Displayport.
So, was ich ganz cool finde, es gibt dieses Einstellungsrädchen, das ist im Prinzip das. Ich habe jetzt ja auch aktuellen BenQ Monitor, da ist bei mir unten im Standfuß drin.
Im Vergleich zu Apple ist da übrigens der Standfuß mit dabei. Man kann hier Profile speichern in den Monitoren quasi hier über dieses Ding dann direkt umschalten.
Das werde ich auch machen. Ich werde mir auf jeden Fall ein Profil machen mit aktivierten Game Features und für den Desktop.
Sieht ein bisschen aus wie eine Maus, ja. Und man kann damit auch das Onscreen Menü bedienen. Das ist die Weiterentwicklung von dem, was ich jetzt ja aktuell gerade am Monitor habe.
Das ist aber wirklich ganz, das habe ich jetzt auch schon, bloß halt am Monitorfuß dran, das ist wirklich ganz praktisch.
Da kann man zum Beispiel sich nämlich Desktop Modus einstellen. Also ich habe es so gemacht, ich habe mein Monitor einmal ein bisschen halbwegs, sofern es geht mit dem Monitor, kalibriert.
Also man kann sich auf zwei Arten kalibrieren. Man kann sich ein Farbprofil rauswerfen lassen und man stellt ein bisschen an den Settings rum.
Ich habe ein bisschen an den Settings rumgestellt, sodass es am ehesten hinkommt. Das heißt, ich habe meinen Desktopbetrieb, habe ich hier eingestellt, dass es die Farben halt am besten aussehen, sofern es mit dem Monitor geht.
Und hier habe ich halt das Gaming Zeug aktiviert, so aktuell zumindest auf meinem Monitor, so werde ich es da auch machen.
So, ähm, ansonsten gibt es an der Seite noch irgendwelche Sachen, ne, die üblichen Geschichten.
So, und was die halt bewerben damit und was auch laut Tests extrem gut ist, ähm, wo haben sie denn die Features stehen?
Genau, einmal dieses Dyack oder was auch immer das ist. Das ist quasi Hintergrund. Könnt ihr euch vielleicht erinnern sich die ein oder andere noch dran?
Ähm, man konnte bei manchen, also bei manchen 144 Hertz-Monitoren, konnte man so Backlight-Strobes einstellen, also sprich, dass der die Hintergrundbeleuchtung an und aus geschaltet hat.
Das hat dazu geführt, dass die Bilder in der Bewegung schärfer wurden. Das war ein bisschen so wie bei einem alten CRT-Monitor,
wo ja das Bild auch nach dem Aufbau einmal quasi komplett refreshed wurde bzw. halt ausgegangen ist für ganz kurze Zeit und dann wieder oben neu gezeichnet wurde.
Ähm, und das ist anscheinend dort eingebaut, also sprich, dass der ähm, quasi zwischen zwei unterschiedlichen Bildern die Hintergrundbeleuchtung irgendwie an und aus schaltet
und deswegen die Bilder in der Bewegung schärfer sind. Das ist richtig nice. Das ist richtig nice.
Das ist richtig nice. Also damit, ich hab das mit meinem BenQ damals ausprobiert, dann hat man aber noch irgendeinen, irgendeinen, BenQ Light...
Wie hieß das denn?
Hier, Light Boost hat man dafür gebraucht. Light Boost hieß der Kram.
Das hab ich damals ausprobiert auf meinem Monitor, der wurde aber schon ein bisschen zu dunkel dadurch.
Ist ja klar, ich meine die Hintergrundbeleuchtung geht aus. Das ist aber ganz cool, dass das eingebaut ist.
Und laut einigen, also viele CS-Pros haben das Ding und das soll wohl echt was bringen.
So und was auch cool ist, ist das hier und die Videos, die ich davon gesehen hab, grenzen fast schon an ein bisschen Cheaten.
Ich guck mal, ob ich euch das Video dazu zeigen kann.
Da hab ich vorhin ein cooles Video gesehen zu...
Weil gerade in Modern Warfare gibt es viele dunkle Ecken, weil sich die Map-Designer gedacht haben.
Ah, hier irgendwo. Weil sich die Map-Designer ja gedacht haben, ist ganz toll.
Genau, hier zeigt das. Guckt euch das mal an, das ist richtig nice. Jetzt hat das aus.
Und jetzt macht das an. Ich mein klar, das Bild wird insgesamt auch ein bisschen heller.
Aber du siehst halt alles in der Ecke. Das ist schon cool.
Es ist fast schon ein bisschen gecheatet, ja. Ich mein, guckt euch alle klar.
Ich mein, das ganze Bild wird ein bisschen heller.
Und da schaltet es jetzt gleich auch noch ein bisschen runter.
Also man kann ähnliche Sachen wahrscheinlich auch erreichen, indem man die Game-Helligkeit einfach sehr hoch stellt.
Aber ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das besser funktioniert als einfach nur die Game-Helligkeit hoch stellen.
Das muss ich mal ausprobieren.
So. Das sind so zwei Sachen, die finde ich eigentlich ganz cool.
Aber das sind nicht wirklich die Sachen, die mich überzeugt haben.
Hauptsächlich überzeugt hat mich, dass ich einfach mal geschaut habe, was die meisten CS-Pros verwenden.
Und da kannst du eigentlich selten falsch liegen.
Ja, die Zeiten hier, da muss man nicht allzu viel drauf geben, was da teilweise drin steht. Blablabla.
Aber ich habe Tests gelesen vom quasi mehr oder weniger fast baugleichen Vorgängermodell.
Die sind alle absolut top, wenn nicht sogar der Beste in der Kategorie.
Und wenn CS-Pros den Spielen auch privat bei sich, da kann man damit eigentlich nicht viel verkehrt machen.
Die meisten Pros können auch mit 60 Hertz krass sein.
Das bezweifle ich, dass Pros freiwillig mit 60 Hertz spielen.
Natürlich sind Pros besser als andere Spieler, aber warum sollten die sich absichtlich gimpen?
Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Ja, wenn du Videos und Fotos machen willst, dann ist das nicht der richtige Monitor.
Aber es geht auch halbwegs zumindest für YouTube-Verhältnisse gut genug.
Ich habe hier so ein Kalibrier-Ding. Ich habe hier so ein Monitor-Kalibrier-Ding. So ein Teil hier. Moment.
Images. Das hängt mir vor dem Monitor. Das hängt mir vor dem Monitor.
Und kann dann ein Testprogramm laufen lassen und kann gucken, wie gut der Monitor kalibriert ist.
Das hängt man so davor. Das ist tatsächlich echt nice.
Aber es geht. So teuer sind die Dinger gar nicht mehr.
Es gibt auch neue. Spider Calibration.
Ja, natürlich haben die irgendwelche Pro-Varianten.
Ich habe irgendwie 120 Euro oder so dafür bezahlt damals.
Gibt es auch in unterschiedlichen Ausprägungen.
Ich habe irgendwie 120 Euro oder so bezahlt. Hier, sowas da.
Und da gibt es dann zwei Modi. Man kann entweder sich ein Farbprofil generieren lassen, was man in Windows lädt.
Und alles ist direkt kalibriert. Oder man stellt an den Settings ein bisschen rum.
So. Und für meine YouTube-Verhältnisse reicht das, wenn ich den Monitor so über den Daumen gepeilt kalibriert habe.
Ist genug.
So. Also.
Ja, das Ding habe ich mir bestellt. Mal gucken, wenn es ankommt und was es taugt.
Also wenn das Ding irgendwie großartige Pixelfehler hat, geht es sofort wieder zurück.
Das gebe ich mir heutzutage nicht mehr. Vor allem nicht bei einem Monitorpreis von 530 Euro.
Full HD ist mir lieber als höhere Auflösung und wenig FPS. FPS Beste.
Mehr FPS, größer Auflösung.
Wozu sollte ich in 1044p spielen und 20% weniger FPS?
Kannst du einen guten 4K-Monitor empfehlen? Nee, kann ich nicht.
Einzige, wo ich die Playstation angeschlossen hatte mit 4K, ist mein Fernseher.
Und da ist halt kein Monitor, da ist er ein bisschen groß.
Also was gibt es denn als nächstes für tolle neue Windows 10 Features, die wir uns noch nicht angeguckt haben?
Das hatten wir uns schon angeguckt. Das hatten wir uns auch schon angeguckt.
Netzwerk, Status, Zeit, Sprache, Geräte, Maus.
Verwaltung verschlimmbessert. Okay, das klingt natürlich schon mal wieder ziemlich Pains Jam.
Die Verwaltung optionaler Windows Funktion hat Microsoft gleichzeitig verbessert und kaputt gespielt.
Sie befindet sich in den Einstellungen im Untermenu Apps, Apps und Features, Optionale Features.
Excellent, Microsoft.
Okay, Features. Das probieren wir jetzt mal aus. Müssen wir eben machen, weil wir müssen WSL aktivieren.
Aber das alte Menü, das alte Menü gibt es immer noch. Sehr gut.
Feature.
Apps und Features.
Optionale Features. Das ist wieder super versteckt.
So, kann ich da WSL installieren? Ach, installed ist das da unten.
Was ist denn da? Standardmäßig alles installiert.
Wordpad.
Internet Explorer 11. Ah, yes. Den brauche ich unbedingt.
Den brauche ich unbedingt. Ah, ja. Exzellent, exzellent, exzellent.
Okay, add Feature.
Okay, was schreiben wir über Heißes dazu?
Einerseits klappt das Hinzufügen von Features nun komfortabler,
denn man setzt zunächst Häkchen vor alle gewünschten Funktionen, lässt sie dann per Klick in einem Rutsch ins Ziel.
Ungünstig ist aber, dass sich alles neu hinzugefügt und danach nicht mehr...
Was?
Hä?
Microsoft, was ist los mit euch?
Wie? Ich kann das nicht mehr entfernen.
Manchmal denke ich mir, die wollen mich verarschen, ja?
Manchmal glaube ich echt, die wollen mich verarschen und das ist gar nicht dann das finale Update.
Okay, das muss ich mir jetzt angucken, ob das echt so ist.
Also, was? Kann man hier WSL installieren?
Nee, Linux.
Warum nicht?
Sub...
Warum kann ich denn hier drüber kein WSL installieren?
Das geht nur übers alte Menü und warum kann ich das Fenster nicht bewegen?
WSL, das ist diese Linux-Geschichte, die auf Windows läuft.
Okay, also, äthiopische Unterstützungs-Fonds, die wollte ich schon immer mal installieren, na exellent.
WSL installieren wir auch gleich noch, das ist jetzt ja angeblich WSL 2 am Start.
Okay, ist installiert.
Ist das jetzt fertig, dass es da oben mit vollem Balken drin steht, ist das fertig oder macht es noch was?
Okay, man weiß es nicht genau.
Okay, optional features.
Ah, jetzt ist es weg, okay.
Äthiop, da ist es doch.
Uninstall.
Okay, das war wohl ein Bug, den haben sie schon gefixt.
Das geht nämlich mittlerweile, man kann Sachen wieder installieren.
Craygasm, Wahnsinn.
Man freut sich ja schon über absolute Basisfunktionen.
Okay.
Feature.
Das heißt, WSL muss ich hier drüber installieren.
Tatsächlich.
Aber das ist das alte, oder? Das ist das alte WSL.
Wie installiert man, wie installiert man Subsystem?
WSL 2, wie installiert man, wenn über den Store, früher hat man das über den Store installiert, mit Ubuntu über den Store suchen.
Okay, schauen wir erst mal weiter.
Schauen wir erst mal weiter.
Verwaltung verschlimm besser, das hatten wir gerade.
Gut, das juckt mich jetzt nicht.
Beim Zurücksetzen.
Beim Zurücksetzen von Windows in den Einstellungen unter Updates, Sicherheit.
Diese Menüs in Untermenüs, das ist so eine Zumutung unter Windows.
Update und Sicherheit, Wiederherstellung, diesen PC zurücksetzen.
Soll Windows auf Wunsch auch setup, na juckt mich nicht.
Apps und Tools, oh jetzt, oh.
Excellent, Big Brain Moves kommen jetzt.
Die Taschenrechner App hat nun einen Grafikrechner eingebaut.
Ah, yes.
Schon etwas länger gibt es außerdem einen Widget Modus.
Aha, das hat die Welt gebraucht.
Calculator.
Scientific.
Und wie kommt man da rein jetzt?
Scientific kann ich halt sowas eingeben wie x gleich, ne.
Programmer, ne.
Standard, was, Standard und, ah, meine, ne.
Das ist ein anderer Knopf.
Hm.
Ich bin immer überrascht, wie kompliziert die Sachen sind.
X.
Functions.
Hm.
Wie kommt man da rein?
Crafting, Crafting, okay, Crafting, Crafting.
Gibts bei mir nicht.
Denied.
Gibts nicht mehr.
Haben sie rausgenommen.
War kaputt.
Gut, dann, dann geht das schonmal nicht.
Sehr gut, nächste.
Note, oh, oh, Leute, jetzt wirds, jetzt wirds advanced.
Jetzt wirds Big Brain.
Gibts nicht im englischen Windows.
Warum sollts das nicht im englischen Windows geben?
Vor allem Crafting hört sich ja überhaupt nicht.
Der Editor Notepad.
Ist auch als Windows Editor im Store verfügbar.
Was?
Oh, der Notepad kommt jetzt über den Store.
Okay, super.
Jetzt kann ich Notepad über den Store installieren.
Na, da bin ich.
Übrigens, das ist auch so ne Sache.
Die fuckt mich unglaublich bei UVP-Anwendungen ab.
Wenn die so ein Slider-Menü haben, wenn man hier draufklickt,
würde man jetzt erwarten, nachdem ich geklickt hab, kann ich direkt tippen.
Nein, kann ich nicht.
Ich muss erst aufmachen, Search klicken und dann nochmal rein,
je nachdem, wo ich die Maus habe.
Richtig fail.
Notepad.
Windows Notepad.
Nice.
Find ich lustig.
Es gibt Windows Notepad echt, oh, Screenshots.
Exzellent.
Ich glaube, ich werde Notepad nicht über den Store installieren.
Sondern einfach hier.
So, also der Task-Manager zeigt ein paar mehr Details als zuvor.
Zum einen steht im Performance-Tab bei Datenträgern
und auch um was für Medentypen.
Gut, es ist in der VM relativ uninteressant.
GPU-Temperatur auch relativ uninteressant.
Quartaner haben wir ausprobiert, geht nicht richtig.
Barrierefreiheit ist für mich erstmal nicht so relevant.
Die Augensteuerung soll nun Track-and-Drop unterstellen.
Das stelle ich mir lustig vor.
Wie man mit der Augensteuerung Track-and-Drop macht.
Ja, das ist wirklich richtig big brain.
Neues für Entwickler.
Beim Sideloading von MSIX-App-Paketen muss künftig die Sideload-Option
in Einstellungen unterblabla nicht auf eingeschaltet werden.
Ja, das ist super.
Das Problem ist, dass man immer noch ein 300-Euro-Codesigning-Zertifikat braucht.
Und da kann mich Microsoft mal...
Oder vielleicht gibt es das auch ein bisschen billiger,
aber warum soll ich mir ein Zertifikat kaufen, ne?
Okay, das Windows-Subsystem...
Es liegt nun in Version 2 vor.
Statt der bisher üblichen...
Ja, genau, das will ich ausprobieren.
Das will ich ausprobieren.
Oberfläche, IP-Kameras...
Virtuelle Desktop lassen sich jetzt umbenennen.
Okay, okay, das ist nicht schlecht.
Aktuell heißen die Dinger ja immer Desktop 1, 2, 3, 4.
Das ist tatsächlich sowas irgendwie halbwegs Praktisches.
Und wie benennt man die um?
Ah, rename.
CacW, LulW, größer CacW, perfekt.
Okay, das klappt.
Fazitfeature.
Da hat wahrscheinlich ein Microsoft Mensch 5 Minuten für gebraucht.
Dazu glüht es in der Übersicht der aktiven Anwendung.
Ja, ich mach das eh mit Shortcuts, ich mach das mit nichts anderem.
Jo, mich nicht.
Datenschutz.
Das lese ich mir jetzt nicht alles durch.
Die von CT bereitgestellten und noch für 2019 nach wie vor empfohlenen Rektatei namens Cortana, geh weg.
Cortana, geh weg, da fällt mir nur zu einen.
Piss dich, Aldo.
Gefunkt zu dir nicht mehr, aha.
Stattdessen greift Microsoft mit Vision 20.04 auf einen anderen Registry-Wert zurück.
Ja, natürlich, was sonst.
Okay, also dann schauen wir doch mal.
Wie, Aldo?
WSL.
Dann schauen wir doch, install WSL 2 Windows 10 20.04.
20.04.
Okay, Moment, wie installier ich das?
Also install, was wir jetzt vorher mal machen, bevor wir das jetzt irgendwie kaputt machen.
Wir machen erst mal einen Snapshot.
Snapshot kann nie Schaden.
Kann Notepad eigentlich noch irgendwas Neues jetzt?
Ich habe gelesen, Notepad kann jetzt Search and Replace.
Stimmt das, stimmt das, dass Notepad jetzt Search and Replace kann?
Das ist das allerwichtigste Feature, was ich schon immer in Notepad gebraucht habe.
Leute, Search and Replace.
Ich habe Jahrhunderte drauf gewartet, dass Notepad endlich Search and Replace hat.
Hat es doch vorher auch schon.
Gebaidet.
Irgendwo habe ich gelesen, dass Notepad jetzt Search and Replace kann.
Habe ich mich da verlesen?
Okay, dann installieren wir jetzt mal WSL und gucken uns das Ganze an.
Schauen wir mal, WSL.
Also, was sagt Microsoft, wie das Ganze funktioniert?
Übrigens, wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Ich muss mal eine Sache gerade mal machen.
Chrome.
Haha, guck mal.
Wie sie auf Bing den Leuten das erst mal unterjubeln wollen.
So wie du willst Chrome downloaden?
Der neue Microsoft Edge ist hier.
Das machen wir aber trotzdem nicht.
Download, jawoll.
Run.
Kann Notepad nicht die ganze Zeit?
Ja, anscheinend schon.
Ich dachte, ich habe es irgendwo gelesen, dass es jetzt neu ist.
Ich muss wissen, ich verwende nicht so viel Notepad normalerweise, um Sachen zu machen.
Ich habe Notepad eigentlich so gut wie nie auf.
Dazu auch.
Akena sagt, er schaut gerade mit dem neuen Edge.
Exzellent.
Okay, also WSL 2 installieren.
Wie geht das?
Wir haben es doch hier stehen.
Install WSL 2.
Open PowerShell as Administrator.
Dism.
Exe.
Online.
Enable Feature.
Microsoft Windows Subsystem Linux.
All no restart.
Moment.
Warum muss ich updaten zu Version 2?
Ich will nicht updaten zu Version 2, ich will einfach Version 2 installieren.
Was?
Tempo.
Was zum Teufel?
Okay, was passiert, wenn ich da WSL eingebe?
Würde das hässliche CMD Fenster mal aufmachen.
WSL.
Ah, nicht ESL.
Fast.
Okay, WSL auch nicht.
Das ist eine Temporary Experience.
Meine Güte, kann ich den einfach ein Knopf machen hier, bitte WSL 2 installieren?
Das geht auf der VM.
Doch, doch, das geht auf der VM.
Nested Virtualisierung funktioniert.
Na gut.
Install WSL 2, not install WSL.
Ich will das alte gar nicht haben.
Na gut, wisst ihr was, wir machen es nach der offiziellen Microsoft Anleitung und gut ist.
Okay.
Also.
Okay, das müssen wir als Admin machen.
Was auch sonst.
Run, yes, zack.
Enabling Features.
Oh, progress bar.
Otherwise wait to restart.
Update to WSL 2.
Haben wir?
Enable the Virtual Machine Platform.
Okay, das ist Hyper-V wahrscheinlich.
Geht das Sub-Sound heute nicht?
Eine gute Frage.
Ich glaube, das Sub-Sound geht heute nicht.
Das müssen wir gleich mal testen, ob das Sub-Sound nicht geht.
Also Feature enabled.
Set WSL 2 as default.
Okay, excellent.
Aha, muss man bestimmt neu starten.
Reboot.
Oh, jetzt habe ich Shutdown gemacht.
Na gut.
Oh, oh, er macht Dinger.
Er macht Dinger.
Ach stimmt, ich soll ein PowerShell Fenster aufmachen, haben sie gesagt, oder?
Ah, ich habe ja kein PowerShell Fenster aufgemacht.
Ich muss ein PowerShell Fenster aufmachen.
Stimmt, ja, wir sind ja, wir sind ja 2020 bei Microsoft.
Ja, ja.
Excellent.
Wann kommt denn die neue PowerShell?
Soll eine neue PowerShell kommen?
Wusste ich nichts von.
Habe ich nicht gesehen.
Mittlerweile kannst du sogar PowerShell unter Linux verwenden.
PowerShell, ich habe ja mal sogar ein PowerShell Buch mir gekauft vor Jahren,
ein bisschen da, mich ein bisschen gelernt, ein bisschen PowerShell gelernt.
Und ich muss sagen, PowerShell ist für Windows-Automatisierung richtig nice.
PowerShell ist aber eine scheiß interaktive Shell.
Geht überhaupt nicht gut von der Hand.
Teinsa, drei Abos gibt es hier wieder.
Excellent.
Exquisite Subscriptions hier.
Für den neunundfünfzigsten Sub, den er schon verschenkt hat.
Meine Güte.
Wer hat was gekriegt?
John hat eine DVD.
BeatBroad und xhec yx.
Sehr schön.
Massive IQ geht nach oben.
Okay, dann machen wir das mit PowerShell.
Auch als Admin starten.
WSL Set Version 2 müssen wir machen.
Okay.
Also muss ich doch das hier machen.
Scheint echt kompliziert zu sein, das hier zu erzählen.
Okay, also download the latest WSL2 Linux kernel package.
Das ist ja, das geht ja, das geht ja so was von easy von der Hand den Kram zu installieren.
Oh.
Yes.
WinGet, ja dann versuch mal zu removeen das neue Terminal.
Install Linux kernel run.
You will prompt, ja, ja, ja.
Ach, das war's.
Okay.
Okay, das heißt haben wir jetzt gemacht.
Install your Linux Distribution of Joys.
Ja, da gibt es ja nur eine.
Ja, auf dem Desktop würde ich die nicht verwenden.
So, get.
Der Store sieht ein bisschen anders aus.
2004 LTS macht er glaube ich standardmäßig.
Ich glaube der macht hier immer die LTS Version mit.
Hier, geht grad ab, flutscht.
Okay, und wie geht's weiter?
Select get setup your distribution.
Okay, ich soll einfach Ubuntu starten, machen wir doch.
Ah, ich so, ich kann Cortana updaten, das noch schlechter wird.
Da können wir den neuen Task Manager bewundern, die neuen Task Manager Features.
Ach so, nee, in der VM sehen wir die ja nicht.
Das war Mbits, jaja.
Mega, Megabyte wäre ein bisschen viel.
Macht das jetzt was?
Ob der was macht?
Ja?
Woher weißt du das?
Ich seh nix.
Testest du dann gleich Docker?
Ja, das können wir machen.
Ah, da haben wir es, da sind wir.
Also, da wollen wir mal enter username, test, Passwort, 123456, 123456, jawoll.
Excellent.
Und wie kann man jetzt überprüfen, wie kann man jetzt überprüfen, ob man in WSL2 ist?
Was haben wir hier für Netzwertkarten?
Is, wird, WSLLV.
Ah, wer soll es mal hier?
Ah, in PowerShell.
Nee, ich dachte, ob man das irgendwo, man müsste es doch irgendwo hier in der VM auch sehen, ob man in Hyper-V läuft.
In der Red Hat gibt es jetzt, wird, wird what?
Ach doch, tatsächlich?
Cool.
Abinstall.
Der check, jaja, der checkt nämlich für ein, auf was man läuft.
Okay, wir müssen erst mal updaten.
Ah, hier ist Desktop mit J5LO, alles klar.
In der ANNL-A, da dürfte man nur die kernel-Version sehen, oder?
Nicht unbedingt, dass man auf einer, dass man auf einer VM läuft oder so.
Ah, guck mal da.
Ach, tatsächlich.
Ah, das ist, das ist, okay, das ist gut zu wissen.
Das ist gut zu wissen.
Hyper-V.
Das ist das, was ich meine, Hyper-V, ajaja.
Also es ist definitiv WSL 2.
Was ich schon immer mal probieren wollte, was passiert eigentlich bei einem Reboot als Root in WSL?
Ah, geht nicht.
Hätte mich auch gewundert.
Chat, ah, der Cute-Mod ist am Start.
Running low on cuties, ja.
Okay, wir sind auf jeden Fall auf WSL 2.
Da müssen wir jetzt erst mal das aller, das allerwichtigste installieren.
Absearch Ascii-Quarium.
Gibt's das überhaupt unter Ubuntu?
Nein, gibt's gar nicht.
Es gibt kein Ascii-Quarium unter Ubuntu.
Ubuntu sackt.
Na gut.
GUI-Anwendungen werden nicht funktionieren,
es sei denn, ich installiere mir noch einen X-Server auf Windows.
C-Matrix, C-Matrix kann man installieren, ja.
Okay, also installieren wir das ab.
Insta, brauchen wir einen Wim und einen T-Max, waren wir noch drauf.
Ach, ist schon installiert, okay.
Schau an.
Ah, jetzt so.
Wenig, ups, verklickt.
Aber es läuft weiter.
Das ist das Schöne, wenn man die Sachen in T-Max-Session speichert, startet.
Sollte mit WSL 2 nicht die GUI kommen, ich habe ehrlich gesagt legit keine Ahnung.
Das können wir mal ausprobieren.
Echo, Display, äh, Echo, Display?
Nö.
Aber wir können, wir können, oder, wir können mal, ähm,
abinstall, xis, oder wie das hieß, ich weiß aber nicht, in welchem Paket das drin ist.
Ah, x, x11 apps.
Xis, kann Open Display, nein.
Ja, xGlock könnte man auch machen, genau.
Kommt doch das gleiche raus, xCock ist auch im gleichen Paket drin.
Ne, anscheinend nicht.
Also man könnte das machen, ich könnte, ich könnte einen xRiver installieren auf Windows, aber wozu?
So, ähm, also T-Max haben wir am Start, schon mal das allerwichtigste, den Wim haben wir auch, der funktioniert.
Bei der Gelegenheit, wo ist das neue Windows Terminal?
Terminal.
Wo ist das neue, hier, das neue Windows Terminal.
Ja, ich kann das Display exportieren, aber das wäre sehr merkwürdig, wenn das was bringt.
Normalerweise setzt er die Gramm, selbst wenn was da ist.
xis, äh.
Ne, ne, vielleicht mal ohne, sollte aber keinen Unterschied machen.
Ok, neue Windows Terminal, drauf.
No.
Yes.
Wie oft soll ich das noch klicken?
Launch.
So, und das Schöne, weil wir das jetzt in T-Max gestartet haben, ist, wir können das hier einfach zu machen.
Starten eine WSL-Session.
Ja, Ubuntu-Session.
Sagen T-Max A und sind wieder drinnen.
Poggers.
Was ist das für ein Font?
Der sieht gar nicht so schlecht aus.
Nach dem zweiten Mal hingucken sieht der Font gar nicht so übel aus.
Wie soll ich den Font überhaupt ändern?
Was?
Warum brauche ich, um den Settings-Dialog zu eröffnen, eine zusätzliche App?
Ah, das ist ein JSON-File.
Microsoft, es wäre auch absolut indiskutabel, wenn hier oben stehen würde, welchen Dateityp versucht wird zu öffnen, oder?
Das geht ja nicht.
Look for App in Store, ok, ok.
Ach, hier unten steht's.
Meine Fresse.
Trio Office.
Ja, genau, Trio Office brauche ich jetzt.
Das ist...
Das ist ein Open Office?
Das ist ein Open Office, warum?
Warum ist das Trio Office?
Das ist ein, ja, oder Depot Office, das ist ein ganz normales Open Office.
Was mich wieder zu der eigentlichen Schlussfolgerung führt, der Microsoft Store ist absoluter Joke im Endeffekt.
Angeblich hat das In-App-Käufe.
Stimmt.
Wo?
Was?
Man kann ja hier drin nicht suchen, ne?
F. Stand weiter oben.
Office In-App Purchases.
What the fuck, Alter?
Ok, also machen wir Settings.
Na gut, dass wir doch jetzt das neue Notepad installiert haben.
Ah, yes.
Font.
Ok, kann man nicht auswählen, standardmäßig.
Ist mir zu doof zu suchen, wie man Fonts ändert.
Wir lassen einfach mal den Standard-Font.
Man kann wenigstens, man kann wenigstens ein bisschen größer machen, das ist doch schon mal was.
So, wichtigste Sache.
Wim erst mal aufmachen, gucken, dass der Maus-Modus nicht an ist.
Der Maus-Modus ist nicht an, beste.
Ah, der Kram geht auch noch.
Also ich muss sagen, das Windows-Terminal fühlt sich tatsächlich jetzt relativ schnell an.
Ich weiß noch, es hat mich das letzte Mal was dran gestört.
Hat Windows einen standardmischen CLI-Editor? Ja, Edit hieß das mal.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es das immer noch gibt.
Edit, Wim, Info.
Ach Moment, das ist ja Linux.
CMD. Früher, früher gab es mal Edit.
Aber gibt es anscheinend nicht mehr.
Hardware-Rat schreibt mich gerade an, hey Max, bist du nicht ein Netzwerk-Profi?
Chat, was soll ich ihn antworten?
Ich bin Fivehead in allem.
Live-Supporte im Stream.
Excellent.
Ich schreibe mal, ich antworte auf sowas immer, geht so.
Geht so ist so unverfänglich als Antwort.
So, also, schauen wir mal.
Was kann man hier schönes machen?
Also wir sind jetzt ja richtig, was Windows angeht, richtig Bleeding Edge unterwegs.
Das allerneueste Windows, das allerneueste WSL.
Das Windows Terminal, das neueste Windows Terminal.
Und das alles über PowerShell installiert.
Also das ist schon mal, das ist schon mal den einen oder anderen Prime-Sub wert, bin ich der Ansicht.
Was kann WSL 2 mehr?
Der Unterschied zwischen WSL 1 und WSL 2 ist zum hauptsächlichen, dass WSL 2 komplett in der Hyper-VVM läuft.
Und angeblich dadurch, falls System-Performance besser ist und irgendwelche Mount-Geschichten und frag mich.
Muss man Microsoft lesen?
Ich weiß es auch nicht genau aus dem Kopf.
Niels Sitt, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön.
Excellent, funktioniert jedes Mal, Dankeschön.
Und ich will mal C auf und schreibe mal das allerwichtige rein.
Alt, Maus, Maus, No. Nur mal für den Fall der Fälle, dass der gleich den Maus-Modus wieder einschalten will.
Okay, da installieren wir mal, wir installieren uns mal einen Docker.
TCP-Dump, sehr gute Idee.
Das wird wahrscheinlich funktionieren, dadurch, dass es jetzt eine VM ist.
Aber er wird wahrscheinlich, aber er wird wahrscheinlich nicht das richtige.
Also wenn ich mal einen Stream-Traffic sehe, dann macht er das Richtige.
Was brauchen wir denn hier? ETH 0?
Sitt haben wir noch zu bieten. Sitt 0.
TCP-Dump, minus V, minus I, ETH 0.
Sieht nicht so aus, Moment, wir müssen die Namensauflöse noch umschalten.
Hallo, ich bin da hoch.
Wir müssen die Namensauflöse noch ausschalten, um auf Nummer sicher zu gehen.
Ah, 10, 10 MBit-Netzwerk. Ping, ping.
Google.
Ja.
Nee.
Also TCP-Dump kannst du nicht verwenden, außer für deine VM.
Was aber auch logisch ist im Hinblick, dass es eine Hyper-VVM ist.
Oh ja, was ist denn jetzt los? Jetzt habe ich einmal nicht hingeguckt.
Der Patrick verschenkt 10 Stufe 1 Abos. Gab es heute Monatsgehalt?
Huge.
Massive.
Wir hatten das Glück, die Abos zu kriegen hier.
Shai Shin hat eins gekriegt. Snitcher, Baba, Boy, Boss.
Der Name ist top.
XDXDXD, der hat es verdient. Wenn es einer verdient hat, dann XDXDXD.
Captain Falcon kriegt eins. Kuchendienst, Skillkiller, Nirvana HD, Perky, Agnostic, Eye-Ondel und Eye-Beindel.
Richtig, Poggas. Heute ist es wirklich hier im Chat.
Das kann man eigentlich schon gar nicht mehr in ein Emote fassen, wie es hier steil aufwärts geht.
Und jetzt fängt auch noch der Scam-Drain an.
WSL ist keine Hyper-VVM. Wieso, was ist es denn sonst?
Also mein Linux ist der Meinung, wenn ich es frage, auf was es läuft,
dass es Hyper-V ist. Und ich würde es auch wundern, wenn WSL 2 nicht so was wie Hyper-V wäre.
Weil sie haben ja selbst gesagt, dass es der große Unterschied zu WSL 1 ist.
Big IQ Boost, aber Massive. Das ist ja schon wirklich Sixhead.
Ich habe jetzt 4 angekommen.
In der Schweiz heißt es nicht Hartz 4, sondern... Was ist denn der höchste Berg in der Schweiz?
Keine Ahnung.
Zugspitze 4. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo das alles liegt.
Jetzt kommt der Tainser nochmal hinterher. Jetzt fliegen aber die Subs hier.
Das ist ja gerade schon...
Der Tainser nochmal 5 Stufe 1 Abos verschenkt. Und zwar, wer kriegt es denn jetzt ab?
Xfaceless17, Dro M. Dro M ist auch öfters da, der hat es auch verdient.
BasFanation, wie auch immer man das ausspricht.
Der BasTV, der hat es auch verdient, den kenne ich. Der ist schon öfters am Start gewesen.
Und G-Stells90, kommt mir auch bekannt vor.
Richtig Big Brain Subs.
Krasser Scheiß.
Ja, das können wir ausprobieren, ob TCP da am funkzehnt. Ich mache einfach mal den Browser auf und...
Hallo?
Ich habe einen Kackbrowser aufgemacht und sage hier google.de und stelle fest, nope, geht nicht.
Ohje, Kackwaves.
Nice. Ah, sehr gut. Also jetzt geht es echt.
Da können wir wieder eine Runde Sub-Counterraten machen heute. Am Ende.
Ok, also.
Wo war man jetzt bei der ganzen Sache stehen geblieben hier?
Ich muss mal kurz dabei gucken, dass ich nicht doch noch irgendwelche Subs übersehen habe hier.
Die Gifted Subs stehen da überhaupt nicht richtig drinnen.
Ja, das ist ja Fail.
Das ist ja Fail.
Alter, was ist denn jetzt los? Ich komme jetzt zu gar nichts mehr.
Alter, jetzt übertreibst du mich nicht. 20 Subs, was ist denn heute los?
Der Scam Train geht steil.
Der Patrick hat auch mal 20 Subs gegiftet. Wir sind beim Hype Train Level 5.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass der Hype Train überhaupt bis Level 5 geht.
Das ist hier mind blown, Alter.
Wer hat es denn heute abgekriegt, bzw. wer hat es denn jetzt abgekriegt? Prototyp95 hat was gekriegt. Licky Brain.
Ist klar. Luminatronik. Lumix1237. Der Name sagt mir auch was. Ich glaube, da ist auch schon eine Weile dabei.
Maurice oder Maureice. Ich glaube, es soll Maurice heißen. Gehe ich mal voraus.
Jazzhammer. Squarty. SpaceChamTV. Herz390. Herz390 ist auch öfters am Start.
Ich kenne so die üblichen Verdächtigen schon.
MonsterVisionGear. THK. MrLove. Kraluk. Pepe. Exzellent. Name, by the way.
Geysi123. LevinCostayo. PotatoChurchman. Mischews. Toxics. Nee, nee, nee. Oh, falsch. Toxics.
Alles klar. Und BatistaGLL. Wäre das DLL gewesen, wäre das richtig Next Level.
Aber die Sub-Sounds kommen kaum noch hinterher gerade.
Jetzt wird die Steuererklärung anstrengend. Ja, ich merke es schon. Richtig anstrengend.
Ja, es gab Überstunden heute.
Nice. Ja, Dankeschön für die ganzen Subs heute.
Ich habe gerade festgestellt, dass ich das in Steam Labs gar nicht richtig sehe.
Das heißt, wenn ich es live nicht mitkriege, ist das ganz schön fail.
Steam Labs hat da so eine extra Übersicht dafür, wo man aber irgendwie nicht wirklich reinschaut.
Ja, danke für die ganzen Subs, die es heute gegeben hat. War richtig massiv bis jetzt.
Ja, falsch, das falsch, die Mod. Ich pock.
So, ich habe jetzt komplett vergessen, den Faden verloren, wo wir stehen geblieben sind.
Genau, also wir wollen Docker ausprobieren, stimmt.
Also wir haben festgestellt, es ist so eine Art Hyper-V, wo das Ganze läuft.
Wir gucken mal, ob Docker-Container jetzt funktioniert.
Da muss man unter Ubuntu immer Docker.io installieren. Aber das ist schon installiert, oder?
Nee, nee.
Der Sub-Sound kommt überhaupt nicht hinterher, Docker.io.
Die haben nämlich das Problem unter Ubuntu, dass sie ein anderes Paket haben, was schon Docker heißt.
Deswegen muss man immer Docker.io installieren.
Aber das muss ja funktionieren. Ich meine, wenn es einfach eine Hyper-V-VM ist,
da gibt es ja keine Ausrede für, dass Docker nicht funktioniert.
Okay, System, CTL, Start, Docker. Passt. Nee. Ach du Scheiße, wie startet man da jetzt Dinger?
Docker? Eigentlich müsste es ja Container-D sein.
Wow.
Mal noch was ganz anderes. Wie rebootet man eigentlich den WSL?
Wie rebootet man WSL? Reboot WSL 2.
WSL minus Shutdown. Ah ja.
Ach so, das meint es gibt einen WSL. Aber das ist bestimmt was anderes.
Die WSManshell. Commandline, was auch immer das ist. WSL Shutdown.
Ubuntu? Okay.
Ah, minus Minus Shutdown. Wir sind ja ohne Windows.
Ah, nice, nice, nice. Das ist ja cool.
Dann machen wir hier zu. Und wenn man es jetzt neu aufmacht, ist es dann wieder da?
Ha, nice. Sehr gut. Das gefällt mir.
Haben wir jetzt Docker laufen? Ja, guck doch mal da. Nee.
Docker geht nicht. Also zumindest startet das Docker nicht automatisch.
Wie kann ich ihm denn sagen, dass ich Docker automatisch starten will, wenn ich kein System D drauf hab?
Nee, nee, nee. User zur Gruppe enden bringt nichts. Das Ding läuft nicht.
Oh, was ist das? Ja, ja, geh weg.
Normal, normal würde ich jetzt sowas machen. System CTL Enable Docker. Docker D.
Ach, hat er es jetzt gemacht? Okay.
Ob er das jetzt macht, wenn ich es nochmal neu starte?
Oder muss man System D installieren? Wie starte ich Dienste oder lasse Dienste automatisch starten über WSL?
Ich mein, was natürlich geht ist, das ist aber jetzt irgendwie nicht im Sinne des Erfinders.
Ich meine, ich kann hier ein Sudo machen. Auf der Seite kann irgendwie dieses Docker Demon starten, der ja im Prinzip ein Link auf Container D ist.
Und jetzt kann ich sagen, Docker PS und dann funktioniert das auch.
Jetzt läuft er nämlich auch, ja. Aber wie kann ich ihm sagen, dass er standardmäßig startet?
Der Karlsson, neun Monate. Dankeschön. Excellent Subscription.
Okay, gibt es irgendetwas? Es gab doch irgendwie so ein Hallo-Welt-Docker-Container. Den probieren wir jetzt.
Das ist das falsche, die falsche VM.
Es gab doch so ein Docker Hallo-Welt-Container zum Testen. Hallo-Welt-Docker, genau.
Wie startet man den Kram? Docker run Hello-Welt.
Ja, geht. Okay, das ist cool. Das gefällt mir, das mach ich. Das gefällt mir schon mal.
Dass man jetzt richtig echtes Docker in WSL laufen lassen kann, das gefällt mir.
Ich mein, es ist nicht so, als wäre es jetzt wahnsinnig nützlich für mich, weil ihr wisst ja, ich hab's ja so.
Ich hab hier mein Windows und ich hab einfach schlicht und ergreifend, es stinkt nochmal Linux vor allem laufen.
Vollwertig nebenbei mit Terminal und allem. Also sprich, ich hab da wenig Anwendungszweck für.
Aber gerade für die Enterprise-Business-Leute, die quasi vom Arbeitgeber an den Windows vorgesetzt bekommen
und sich nicht wehren können dagegen und keinerlei Virtualisierungsmöglichkeiten mit Linux haben, ist das gut.
Das ist wirklich cool. Es gibt ja auch wohl jetzt die Möglichkeit über Visual Studio Code.
Gibt's das eigentlich über den Store? Mittlerweile? Nein.
Ich mein, Microsoft hat ihren Vorzeig ge-edited und nicht mal im eigenen Store. Das ist schon echt fail.
Da weiß ich geil, was ich dazu sagen soll. Das ist wirklich fail.
Weil angeblich kann man doch jetzt unpinnen. Install VS Code.
Weil angeblich gibt's jetzt doch jetzt so ein WSL-Plugin, dass man in Visual Studio Code jetzt
den neuen WSL-Docker-Geschichten irgendwie laufen lassen kann.
Also das kann man bei Gelegenheit auch ausprobieren.
Install mal. Gibt's auch die Cornshell? Klar, klar gibt's die.
Das ist ja ein ganz normales Ubuntu 20.04. Da kannst du ja alles installieren, was du willst.
Du kannst auch eine Fischshell oder sowas installieren.
So, probieren wir das mal aus. Launch Visual Studio. Ja, mach.
Ja, xDxD. Ich hab doch gesagt, du hast das verdient.
Ja, remote ist installiert. Ja, exellent.
No folders, no editors. Okay, wir haben hier ein neues File.
Und wie kann... Ah, Remote Explorer. Was ist das? Ubuntu, Ubuntu.
Ah, guckt mal hier. Jetzt bin ich auf meinem... Das ist cool. Jetzt bin ich auf meinem WSL-Ubuntu drauf.
Guck mal, jetzt bin ich auf meinem WSL-Ubuntu. Das ist natürlich praktisch.
CacW, speichern wir mal. Okay, das ist cool.
Und da kann ich auch Sachen ausführen. Probieren wir das doch mal. Kann ich jetzt eine shell?
Ja, guckt mal. Jetzt sind wir... Oh, das laggt. Alter. Da fuckt die shell laggt wie Sau.
Also, das laggt wirklich hardcore, die shell. Aber das ist gar nicht übel.
Also die Integration in der... Das kann man wirklich gebrauchen.
Aber das ist hier... Ich kenne mal, dass es das nächste Mal ausprobieren wollte. Kann man das von hier starten?
Nee.
Anscheinend nicht.
Ich mein Code Punkt... Du meinst ja schon den hier.
Wahrscheinlich nicht. Ja, Nord.exe habe ich mir auch... Warte mal, ich habe eine Idee.
Das ist wahrscheinlich nicht im Pass drinnen. Und damit es in den Pass reinkommt, ist es Windows.
Muss man neu starten. Kannst du in WSL eine Virtualisierung laufen lassen?
Ja, ich kann QEMO installieren. Ich kann QEMO installieren. Ich könnte auch einen Wine installieren in WSL.
Und dann könnten wir Notepad über Wine in WSL in Hyper-V in Windows ausführen.
Das ist eine exquisite, exzellente Idee. Das sollten wir machen.
Okay, Ubuntu starten? Nein, das ist das Falsche. Das wollen wir gar nicht starten.
Das hier Terminal wollen wir starten. Waren wir hier ohne...
Ja, ich vergaß. Den Mist kann man ja nicht tracken, weil ich Microsoft gedacht habe. Das ist overrated.
Ubuntu starten, TMAX.
Ah, jetzt geht's. Und jetzt connecte das. Das ist tatsächlich cool. Das gefällt mir richtig gut.
Für mich bringt es immer noch nichts, weil ich halt mit Windows und einer Linux VM parallel arbeite.
Aber das ist tatsächlich ganz cool.
Man hat jetzt hier quasi sein Visual Studio Code laufen auf Windows, OS Windows.
Das connectet sich über WSL auf Linux und tut so intern, als wäre es auf einem Linux System ausgeführt.
Das ist zwar voll durch die Brust ins Auge, aber das ist nice.
Und dass es funktioniert, sieht man auch daran, weil ich hier drin das Terminal starten kann und ich dann auf meinem Linux Host bin.
Nur mit dem Unterschied, dass meine Tastatur-Settings sacken.
Wenn man also Sachen kompiliert, wird es für Linux gebaut. Ja, so würde ich das sehen.
Ja, ja, genau.
Wir können es ja mal ausprobieren. Wir installieren jetzt einfach mal.NET Core.
Wie heißt das hier unter Ubuntu?
Absearch.net..NET. Kann es sein, dass das gar nicht dabei ist?
Kann es sein, dass das gar nicht mitgeliefert wird?
Dann installieren wir uns das jetzt einfach. Ubuntu install.NET Core.
Hat das kein Install-Skript oder sowas?
Snap? Oh, Snap wäre richtig big brain, Alter.
Snap wäre eine richtig big brain Idee. Da haben wir noch einen Container dazwischen.
Oh, da bin ich mal gespannt, ob das funktioniert.
Snap. Der müsste es ja mit drauf installen.
Wie heißt denn der.NET Snap?
Einfach nur.NET SDK.
Snap. Die.
Ich frage mich echt, wie ich Sachen automatisch...
Snap install.
Wie starte ich den Kram denn? System, CTL, Start, Snap, Snap die.
Nee. Ach du Scheiße. Kann man...
Oder ist es Snap minus D?
Du große Scheiße.
Kann man ab Install System D machen, dass ich den Kram starten kann?
Weil, meine ich, das geht? Ich glaube ja nicht.
Ich glaube ja nicht, dass ich System D installieren kann.
Snap start? Nee, das ist für Sachen, die schon installiert sind.
Hiermit kannst du VS Code als Docker Container im Browser ausführen.
What the fuck?
Was passiert, wenn ich System D installiere? Geht es dann kaputt?
Geht es dann kaputt?
Da bin ich ja mal jetzt gespannt.
Ja, ich hätte vorher einen Snapshot machen sollen, wenn es zu spät.
Aber ich meine, das Ubuntu Ding kann ich ja neu installieren. Das ist ja kein Problem.
Alter, ich kann... System, CTL, Start, Snap. Nee, das mag er nicht.
Tja, wie starten... You can reload window. Jawoll.
Snap D, start. Snap Demon.
Okay, was... Snap, CTL. Service, Service, Start, Snap.
Okay, ich... Ich weiß nicht.
Aber ich will mal ein.NET Core installieren auf dem... Und dann gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Überwischelst du die Code? Da bin ich echt mal gespannt.
Wie kann ich am besten mal ein.NET Core installieren auf einem Ubuntu 20.04, wenn es nicht im Report drin ist?
So bestimmt nicht. Das ist voll....NET Install Script Ubuntu. Die hatten doch so einen Installer.
Hier, genau, das da brauchen wir doch..NET Install SH. Da ist es doch. Genau, das will ich haben.
Weget. Aber nicht als Root. Weget. Bäm..NET, CRMOD. Ausführbar machen, das Ganze..NET Install SH.
Zack. Ich kann grad nicht tippen. So, und jetzt sollten wir aktuell das.NET installieren.
Was? Warning, ZLIP ist nicht drauf und Curl ist nicht drauf. Dann mal gucken. Installation finished.
Wow. Das ging aber. Das ging aber poggers schnell. Da ist es auch. Guck mal. Da ist es.
Das ging aber echt saumäßig schnell. Also sagen wir jetzt mal Export. Wobei.
Wir sagen jetzt einfach mal, wir brauchen gar nicht.NET. Machen wir eine neue Console App.
Und dann sagen wir hier einmal Verzeichnis..NET..NET. Und dann, was war das? New Console. Irgendwie so. Ja, nice. Nice, nice. Das funktioniert.
Ein Massive POG gibt es ja. Das ist ja. Das ist richtig cool. Guck mal, hier haben wir jetzt eine.NET Anwendung.
Starten wir das mal. Starten wir das mal in Visual Studio Code, was sich jetzt connectet zu meiner VM.
Guckt euch das mal an. Ja, das ist ja nice. Okay, das muss ich zumachen.
Tommy K. sagt, ich programmiere ja viel, aber bin so eine Niete, was die Nuke angeht.
Ich zweifel gerade alles an, das ich in den letzten zwölf Jahren gelernt habe. Warum?
Es ist cool, dass das funktioniert. Das gefällt mir. Das gefällt mir echt. Das hat irgendwie was.
Oh..NET Core SDA can't be located. Ah ja klar, weil ich das nicht richtig exportiert habe. Gehe ich mal von aus.
Path. Was in der Standard Einstellung fügt das Skript? Echt?.NET? Ja oder auch nicht, oder?
Oder auch nicht. Macht es überhaupt nicht. Jebaited.
Was? Man kann auch via Code Plugins nur in dem Workspace in WSL haben. Ah cool.
Denkst du, dass WSL eine Linux VM auf Windows vielleicht mal komplett ablösen wird? Glaube ich nicht. Also mein Skript hat keinen Path hinzugefügt.
Macht es vielleicht, wenn ich es nochmal ausführe. Ja. Adding to Current Process Paths.
Was? Hat er das jetzt richtig gemacht? Path? Sind das da irgendwo drinnen?
Nö, das jebaited mich einfach. Der jebaited mich einfach. Macht er gar nicht. Aber ich meine, ich kann es ja von Hand machen. Bash RC Path.
Haben wir hier irgendwie was? Wie geht das jetzt? Export Path gleich? Path? Wie macht man das nochmal richtig? Path? So? Gucken wir einfach mal.
Ja..NET. Geht. Sehr gut.
Und ob er jetzt.NET findet? Oh. Was? Ja, meinetwegen. Ah, das scheint zu funktionieren. Mal gucken, ob wir dem Ding den Hello World entlocken können.
Ja, nice. Ich mein, so wirklich hundertprozentig sehe ich den Anwendungszweck noch nicht.
Das habe ich doch, genau das habe ich doch gemacht, oder? Oder habe ich verschrieben? Genau das habe ich doch gerade gemacht. Ja.
Mit F5? Geht. Easy. Das ist cool. Das ist cool. Ich meine, wie gesagt, ich habe jetzt nicht so richtig die Anwendung dafür.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall cool, ja. Mit Breakpoint. Geht. Breakpoint. Es funktioniert einfach alles sofort.
Das ist nice. Das hat was. Das hat echt was. Ich mein, so wirklich, wie gesagt, ich kann es, ich habe jetzt 20.000 Mal gemacht.
So wirklich Anwendungszweck dafür habe ich nicht, weil ich habe ja meine Linux-VM-Parallel laufen.
Aber gerade für Leute, die, weil sie von der Firma Windows bekommen, darauf fest genagelt sind, ist das eine wirklich coole Geschichte.
Und auch integrationsmäßig finde ich, finde ich ziemlich gut gemacht. Nice. Das gefällt mir.
Also WSL2 kriegt in der Kategorie schon mal Pluspunkte, dass es einfach zu funktionieren scheint.
Jetzt können wir nochmal was ausprobieren. Nee, können wir nicht. Können wir nicht. Können wir nicht.
Ich wollte sagen, ich kann mal versuchen, was zu mounten, aber das können wir nicht richtig ausprobieren.
Aber nice. Es hat was. Es hat echt was. So, ich habe jetzt lange keinen Chat mehr geguckt, habe ich was übersehen.
Denkst du, dass Linux-VM komplett abgelöst wird davon? Nee, denke ich nicht.
Ja, nein, das muss ich nicht ausprobieren, VS Code im Browser laufen zu lassen.
Nee, kam ja nichts im Chat, was man... Ach hier, benutze VS Code fast nur mit Remote Extension per SSH auf Remote Linux, um dort zu arbeiten.
Stimmt, das könnte man ja auch machen. Geht das über SSH? Kann man mit VS Code über SSH irgendwo arbeiten?
Bisher mounte ich mir das dann immer mit SSH FS, wenn ich irgendwo Remote was editieren muss.
Wie findest du die Linux-Geschichte im Gegensatz zu einem normalen Linux? Sie funktioniert erstaunlich gut mittlerweile.
Aber im Vergleich zu normalen Linux natürlich immer noch meilenweit entfernt.
Allein schon, dass grafische Programme nie richtig funktionieren werden.
Klar, du kannst dir einen X Server installieren unter Windows, aber die Dinger werden nicht so gut laufen wie unter einem ordentlichen X Server unter Linux.
Browser ruckeln. Aber für das, was es sein will, ist es echt nicht schlecht.
Das gefällt mir. So, Leute, soll ich noch irgendwas ausprobieren hier unter Linux?
Weil mir fällt jetzt gerade nichts mal großartig ein.
Generiert daraus dann eine Binary. Kann ich machen, ja. Kann ich machen.
Aber das Binary wird dann nur unter Linux laufen, wenn ich...
Gut, ich kann auch was für Windows generieren, das funktioniert. Kann ich ja mal machen.
Sagen wir mir.NET. Build. Wie geht denn das jetzt? Minus C. Release. So, und dann muss man angeben minus R. Linux X64. War das so?
Ja, schon mal ganz gut. Minus Minus Self-Contained war das nächste, glaube ich. Ach, fuck.
Oder nur Minus Self-Contain...
Publish Single Excel.NET Build. Da muss ich nachgucken, wie das funktioniert.
Ja, Minus Minus Self-Contained habe ich da eingegeben. Ach, Publish war das. Ach, Publish.
Publish Contained. Und dann brauchen wir noch eine Option hinten dran für Single Excel. Genau.
Das braucht man dann auch noch hinten dran. Und jetzt... Ja, ist gut. Ich mache es ja weg.
Und jetzt kriegt man hier ein Executable raus, was unter Linux funktioniert.
Hier. C. Hello World. Da sind wir. Und das Gleiche können wir auch machen für eine Windows-Version.
Da sagt man hier Windows X64. Oder nur... Nee, was sagt man da? Windows? Einfach nur Windows? Win? Win64?
Ah, ja. Exzellent. Alles klar. Voll logisch. So, und jetzt haben wir hier, wenn ich mit dem Explorer mal hingucke,
in den Ordner. Dann haben wir hier unter Bin eine Release-Version. Nee, Moment. Habe ich eine Release-Version
überhaupt gemacht? Genau. Haben wir eine Release-Version. Einmal für Linux, einmal für Windows. Und die Windows-Version,
die geht einfach. Wenn sie dann startet. Vielleicht muss da gerade der Viren-Scanner nochmal scannen.
Guck, da. Geht einfach. Oder sollte. Einfach. Einfach gehen. Theoretisch sollte sie jetzt einfach laufen unter
Windows. Was wahrscheinlich auch funktioniert hat. 64 MB? Ja. Na gut. Was willst du machen?
Zack. Hello World unter Windows. Und einmal die Linux-Version unter Linux. Funktioniert. Gut.
Weil, ich meine, es ist klar, warum das so groß ist. Da ist die komplette.NET Runtime dabei. Man kann es
einen Ticken kleiner machen. Kann ich auch noch sagen, man kann... Mal gucken, ob das hier auch drinne steht.
File-Size. Man kann noch sagen, dass er die Debug-Symbole und sowas rausstrippen soll. Das geht.
Smaller. Das geht. Publish trimmed war es. Genau. Das ist ja auch Option aus der Hölle, wie man die angeben muss.
So. Und jetzt ist es 25 MB groß. Kleiner kriegst du es aber nicht mehr. Wie gesagt, da ist die komplette
.NET Runtime drunter. Drinne. Der entpackt das jetzt unter der Haube in irgendein temporäres Verzeichnis
und updatet das jedes Mal, wenn du eine neue Version hinstiebst. Also der macht ein bisschen... Im Prinzip ist es
mehr oder weniger ein Zip. Intern wahrscheinlich. Mehr oder weniger ein Zip, was halt das Auspacken unter
der Haube macht. 25 MB für den Hello World. Ja, in Anprachung der Tatsache. Also im Vergleich zu einem
Rust ist es relativ groß. Aber dass eine komplette.NET Runtime drinne ist. Ja, dafür ist es klein.
Und ganz ehrlich, Who Cares 25 MB heute. Nee, braucht man nicht, Tommy. Du kannst einfach die Exe
verschicken. Guck, ich kann es euch mal zeigen. Ich kann ja jetzt mal hier die... Das nehmen.
Hups. So, ich kann jetzt einfach mal hier die Exe nehmen. Blah, Windows, Publish. Die Exe nehme ich jetzt
mal und track und drop mir die einfach mal in mein Host Windows rüber. Irgendwo hier unter Documents oder
so. Und ihr werdet sehen, die funktioniert ohne Probleme auch auf meinem Host Windows drauf. Also
das ist wirklich eine Sache, die sie mit.NET Core ziemlich gut hinbekommen haben. Unterstützt wird
standardmäßig... Ja, wenn du es ohne Framework kompilierst, das stimmt, dann ist es natürlich
deutlich kleiner. Aber es läuft halt nur auf Rechner, wo in irgendeiner Art und Weise eine aktuelle
.NET Core Version bereitgestellt wird. Das dürften die wenigen global installiert haben. Also da bleibt
dir eigentlich nichts anderes übrig, als eine self-contained Single Exe irgendwie zu machen,
dass du das unter die Leute bringen kannst. Die Exe läuft nicht unter Linux, aber die andere läuft
unter Linux. Wir haben ja zwei gemacht. Wir haben ja auch noch eine Linux-Version. Die läuft auch
unter Linux hier. Also es gibt eine Windows-Version und es gibt eine Linux-Version. Aber das Schöne ist,
die Linux-Version läuft auch so gut wie unter allen Linux-Systemen direkt und die Windows-Version
läuft auch unter fast allen Windows-Systemen. Ja klar, du hast nach wie vor zwei verschiedene
executable-Files für Windows und für Linux, aber da kommst du dir auch schwer dran vorbei.
So, jetzt haben wir das ausprobiert. Genau, was soll ich noch ausprobieren hier unter WSL?
Das habe ich gelesen, dass man demnächst auch grafische Programme ausführen können soll.
Die machen dann irgendwie OpenGL zu DirectX-On-The-Fly-Translation.
Aquarium gibt es hier nicht. Ich weiß, was jetzt richtig big brain wäre, wenn ich jetzt Wine
installieren würde. Wenn ich jetzt Wine installieren würde und wir lassen Notepad im Wine über
WSL laufen. Das wäre echt voll um die Ecke. Kannst du auch für ARMv7 kompilieren? Ja.
ARMv7 geht auch. Haben wir sogar schon gemacht. Wir haben noch auf meinem Staubsauger schon
mein Address-Tracking-Programm laufen lassen. Jetzt ohne Scheiß, Leute, auf dem Staubsauger
haben wir das laufen lassen. Kein Witz. X-Forwarding geht, aber was viel cooler wäre,
einen X-Server unter Windows zu installieren? Das können wir jetzt mal ausprobieren.
Wir installieren jetzt einen X-Server unter Windows. Was ist denn ein guter X-Server für
Windows? X-Ming ist der alte, der ist immer angesagt. WSL 2 Graphical Apps. 8GB Pi 4
schon bestellt? Nö, ich sehe keinen Anwendungszweck für 8GB. Ich habe ja nur 4GB. Reicht.
Oh, das ist ja eine Big-Big-Brain-Geschichte hier um die IP rauszukriegen von Windows host.
Poggers. Ja, Wine. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man den Kram überhaupt startet, ehrlich gesagt.
Wie startet man mit Wine überhaupt irgendwas? Ich habe legit keine Ahnung. Wine. Wine CFG.
Wow. Ah, kann kein X-Window createn. Okay. Also, dann machen wir das doch mal. Also,
was brauchen wir für einen X-Server? X-Server Windows. Wine ist auch crap, ja, aber Wine
ist hardcore crap. VCXSRV. Alles klar. Sourceforge, das verwendet noch jemand? Das ist so Wine
Explorer Exe. Das wird nicht funktionieren. Ah, Moment. Wine32. Meine Güte. Okay. Accept.
Download. Wine ist mega crap. Wine ist absolute Shit. Also, wenn man erstmal in die Welt von
Wine einsteigt, dann ist erstmal 5 Stunden Debuggen und Rumfrickeln, bis es halbwegs
funktioniert an der Tagesordnung. Ich weiß, ich weiß, es gibt immer die Leute, die sagen
so nach dem Motto, ah, macht's, ich hab das einfach installiert, das ging sofort. Was
hat man dann installieren? Mein Sweeper oder so. Ja, das mit Wine Explorer Exe kann man
gleich machen, aber ich muss erstmal einen X-Server installieren, wenn ich überhaupt
eine Chance hab, eine grafische Ausgabe zu machen. Erstmal 30 Milliarden Sachen installieren.
Doom Eternal läuft in Wine besser als auf Native Finders. Ja, klar. So. Ah, das ist jetzt
gestartet schon? Nee. Ja, mach was du willst. Start X-Server. Jaja, mach mal. Finish. Allow.
Excellent. Okay, jetzt bin ich mal echt gespannt, ob das funktioniert. Aber XIS müsste jetzt
funktionieren. Oh. 1KS. Okay, dann ist es doch ein bisschen komplizierter, als ich gedacht
hab. What? Okay, keine Ahnung. Ich weiß nicht, was er macht. Ich weiß nicht, was er
macht. Ich weiß. Scheiß drauf. Da ging es jetzt auch bei der ganzen Sache nicht rum.
Ach, stimmt, ja, klar. Ja, stimmt, hast recht. Aber XOS, ja, ich brauch XOS. Stimmt, stimmt,
stimmt. Das brauchst du ja auch für X-Forwarding. Aber vielleicht haben wir sogar schon drauf.
Haben wir drauf. Das hat dann anscheinend damit... Das liegt am Server, da hat irgendwelche Schmerzen
mit. Das Display hab ich schon exportiert, das passt. Das ist die IP von der Windows-Kiste.
Ach so, es könnte sein, dass wir das falsche Display haben. Lock. Es könnte sein, wir müssen
mal die Displaynummer angeben. Vielleicht verwendet er nämlich standardmäßig nicht
null. Null. Null. Nee. Okay, keine Ahnung, was der für Schmerzen hat. Wo soll das vielleicht
irgendwie... Was ist das? Ja, ja, das haben wir. Muss man das vielleicht irgendwie frei
geben? Keine Ahnung, da halten wir uns jetzt aber nicht länger mit auf. So, also. Du musstest
noch den Wizard fertigstellen. Hab ich doch? Oder kommt da noch was anderes? Hab ich doch
hier? Null. Next. Next. Next. Nee, nee, das ist... Ich muss da garantiert das Ganze irgendwie
erst frei geben, dass ich mich connecten darf. Ähm, weil die IP ist ziemlich sicher richtig.
Die IP müsste nämlich das sein von meinem Windows. Ja, das ist die IP von meinem Windows.
Ich muss garantiert dem Ding irgendwie sagen, dass man von überall connecten darf. Oder
auch nicht. Okay. Rude. Was ist mein Geld für? Doch, richtig. Doch, guck mal. Ist richtig.
Ähm, das ist mein Windows. Aber wahrscheinlich lauscht er nicht am richtigen Interface oder
irgendwas. Keine Ahnung, ja. Ähm, nee. Nee, mit Sudo dürfte das nichts zu tun haben. Nee,
guck, kein Schimmer. Weiß nicht, was der für Schmerzen hat. Das lassen wir jetzt auch
genug gebasteln. So, was gibt's denn sonst noch so für tolle neue Windows 10 Features?
Was haben wir denn noch übersehen? WSL, WSL, haben wir uns schon alles angeguckt. So.
Also, was hatten wir sonst noch für Dinger? Das haben wir ausprobiert. Das war gar nicht
so schlecht wie gedacht. Mauszeigegeschwindigkeit haben wir auch ausprobiert. Netzwerkstatus
haben wir ausprobiert. Firewall aus ist tatsächlich eine gute Idee. Das können wir nochmal ausprobieren.
Ähm, wir haben zwar freigegeben, dass der drauf connecten darf, aber man weiß ja nie,
ne? Windows, geh mal aus dem Weg. Man weiß ja nie. Nee. Der meckert auch hier. Der kriegt
da Verbindung zum Server Authorization required, but no authorization protocol specified. Nicht
WSL. WSL. Oh. Ha. Xhost. Oh, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, big, big brand. What the fuck?
Export. Was muss ich da reinschreiben? Was? Xhost. Xhost. Ich rate jetzt einfach nur,
ich rate jetzt einfach nur. Nee, haha. What the fuck? Aber ich glaube, wir haben jetzt
Xhost. Aber Xhost brauchen wir eigentlich nur auf der anderen Seite. Vielleicht nimmt
Xhost auch einfach standardmäßig. What? Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay.
Okay, probieren wir es noch einmal so, ob das funktioniert. Nö. Okay, draufgeschissen.
Ähm, wie ist denn euer Windows 10 Version? Ich muss sagen, die WSL 2 Geschichte ist
erstaunlich gut. Ähm, mit was für einem Programm schreibt ihr eure Dokus und habt
sie zentral gesammelt in der Arbeit? Confluence. Außerdem, wer braucht Dokus? Guter Code dokumentiert
sich selbst. Overrated. Dokus, Kommentare, braucht man alles nicht, wenn man ordentlich
programmiert. Äh, Serious Max, damit habe ich überhaupt nichts zu tun. Damit habe ich
überhaupt nichts zu tun. Bei uns gibt es keine Low Noobs, die auf dem Server irgendwas ausführen.
Es gibt nur Noobs, aber Low Noobs haben wir nicht. So, gibt es auch so irgendwas Schönes,
was mir so direkt ins Auge springt, was neu ist? To Do, komplett useless Crap-Application,
weil die nur online in Microsoft funktioniert und nicht mit normalen Standards wie Kaldorf
oder so. Komplett, komplett useless Shit, die To Do App. Äh, Windows 10 Mail, auch übelster
Crap, kann weniger als Outlook Express, auch Müll. Sehe ich das Skype? Sehe ich das Skype?
Iget. Guck zu einem an. In 2020. Müll. Office habe ich jetzt aufgemacht. Nein, nein, nein.
Warum ist da Wörth dabei? Ach, ne. Gebaited. Gebaited. Erstmal uninstallen, uninstallen, uninstallen,
hier den Shit wegmachen, unpin. Dann sollte es ja nix mehr da. Xing. Uninstall. Warum ist
da eigentlich so viel Scheiße vorinstalliert, hä? Warum ist denn da so viel Kacke vorinstalliert?
Candy Crush, das haben wir schon deinstalliert. Warum ist da so viel Scheiße vorinstalliert?
Your Phone. Excellent. Update. Okay, wir updaten nochmal alles hier. Cortana, Your Phone, Xbox,
Companion. Genau, die brauchen wir unbedingt. Die muss ich unbedingt updaten jetzt alles.
Hatte Windows 10 nicht eine Sandbox jetzt? Wie startet man die Windows 10 Sandbox? Windows
Feature, okay. Was, was natürlich sonst? Feature. Ja, ich hab's noch nie richtig ausprobiert.
Wir haben es mal im Stream probiert. Die Sandbox heißt natürlich nicht Sandbox. Wie heißt
die? Windows Sandbox natürlich. Windows Sandbox. Install. Dann, das, das gucken wir uns nochmal
an. Das ist wirklich ein praktisches Feature, wenn es funktionieren würde. Moment, warte
mal kurz. U-Block. Man kann nie genug U-Block installiert haben. Ganz wenige Benutzer. Ja,
Relax. Ich weiß auch nicht, warum da so viel Müll vorinstalliert ist. Wir probieren jetzt
nochmal die Sandbox aus. Wenn der Browser mal fertig überprüfen ist. Oh, es hängt.
Chrome. Grip. Chrome ist hinüber. Restart now. Was ist heute der Plan? Wir haben uns
die neue Windows Funktion angeguckt, die mit dem neuen Update reingekommen sind. Wir haben
uns WSL2 angeguckt. Was erstaunlich gut funktioniert, muss ich mal sagen. Vor allem die Visual Studio
Integration ist ziemlich nice. Und jetzt gucken wir uns nochmal die Windows Sandbox an. Geht
WSL2 auch mit QI? Nee. Ich habe es gerade probiert, ob ich nicht noch einen Trittanbieter
X Server installieren kann. Hat nicht so richtig funktioniert. Nee, Cortana nervt nicht mehr.
Cortana geht nicht. Cortana ist kaputt. Wenn man es nicht gerade auf US Englisch einstellt,
ist Cortana kaputt. Also nur Original Kokona ist würdig. Cortana zu verwenden. Mit 2004
ist Microsoft macht doch jetzt die Ubuntu Benamung. 2020, April. So, Sandbox. Da ist
sie doch. Die Sandbox App. Serious Max, ich habe die Sandbox noch nie verwendet. Das können
wir jetzt mal ausprobieren. Also es hat schon mal ein tolles Icon. Machen tut es gerade
nichts. Oh doch, VM ja macht Dinger. Da ist sie doch. Nice. Wir dürfen nicht vergessen,
es ist jetzt Nested Virtualisierung. Also in der VM eine VM. Und dafür, also für das,
dass es Nested Virtualisierung ist, kann man sich nicht beschweren, oder? VM in VM funktioniert
doch erstaunlich gut hier. Man hat, ich glaube eher so ein Minimal Windows. So was wie Mail,
ist da so was wie Mail dabei? Oh, RIP. Der Startbutton geht nicht mehr Leute. Oh, Monka
Lack. So was wie Mail ist da gar nicht dabei. Gibt es nicht. Anscheinend hat man da nur
einen Browser, kann das sein? Auch nur einen Edge. Super Funktion. Kann man wenigstens
Chrome installieren? Wie läuft's mit Monka Win? Erstaunlich gut mit VSL 2. So kann man
jetzt hier Chrome drauf installieren und es ist nach dem Neustart noch da? Da bin ich
mal gespannt. Da bin ich mal gespannt, ob das funktioniert. Weil wie kriegt man sonst
in die Sandbox standartmäßig einen gescheiten Browser? Also ich will ja nicht wirklich
den Edge verwenden. Sucht mal nach WinFair für die Win und kann ich machen. Das wird
aber auch, das wird aber auch 2004 sein oder? Das ist bestimmt das gleiche wie auf dem
Host. Ja, das gleiche wie auf dem Host. Ja, aber wenn sich die Sandbox jedes Mal resettet,
ist es ziemlich ja Müll. Da kriege ich ja keinen gescheiten Browser rein. Okay, das
laggt schon ein bisschen, aber es ist auch nested virtualisiert jetzt. Das ist okay.
Das darf laggen. Okay, gucken wir mal bei mir auf YouTube vorbei. Wow. Was? Wowowow.
YouTube. Hat er wieder mein Tastaturlayout umgestellt? Natürlich, was sonst? Ah, es
laggt, es laggt schon hart. Was will der hier? Windows, Windows, was willst du? Monkeys.
Was ist hier los? Ah, Turn on, alles klar, exzellent. Exzellent, machen wir alles. Ja,
ja, mach, mach, mach Windows. Alles gut. Also, surfen in der nested virtualisierten VM ist
fragwürdig. Das funktioniert nicht richtig. Aber die Idee mit der Sandbox finde ich immer
noch ziemlich praktisch. Mal gucken, mit wie viel FPS das Video läuft. Wow. Oh, das ist
ja, das läuft ja fast flüssig. Der Lizenzfuchs. Erst mal eine Runde Windows Lizenz hier. Der
Lizenzfuchs. Oh, jetzt ist abgekackt, Leute. Oder nicht? Oder noch? Mit wie viel FPS läuft
der Kram? Quality. Okay, wir schalten mal kurz runter und gucken mal, ob es dann flüssig
läuft. 144p, exzellent. Ah, Windows, ah? Kann es sein, dass 144p noch schlechter läuft?
Das läuft noch schlechter. Okay, wir starten mal die Sandbox neu, mal gucken, was jetzt
passiert. Oh, fuck, das ist voller Abscheisen. Oh, oh, oh. Sandbox, gib alles. Okay, okay,
ja, Sandbox, ich mach zu, ich mach zu, ist gut, ist gut. Ich quill dich nicht weiter,
Sandbox, alles gut, alles gut. Restart. Was ist das? Das ist die eingebaute Windows Sandbox,
sei es zwei Windows-Versionen oder so ist die dabei. Das ist quasi eine Windows-VM in
Windows mitgeliefert, wenn man, nein, wenn man im Browser Sachen machen will, die man
mit seinem Host vielleicht nicht machen möchte. Ja, ich denke auch, dass alles weg ist. Ist
ja gerade der Sinn von so einer Sandbox, dass nichts da bleibt, dass nichts übrig bleibt.
Da drin jetzt WSL und wieder Wiener, exzellent. Sehr gute Idee. Wie zum Beispiel Poke-Mainstreams
gucken. Ja, zum Beispiel. Ja, ist alles weg. Okay, aber das war klar. Nice. Also ganz ehrlich,
es ist zwar viel bescheuerte Sachen drinne und auch gerade die Menüs, die wieder total
unnötig kompliziert sind. Das, was mir am besten gefällt, ist ja noch nicht mal wirklich
Teil von diesem Windows-Update, ist WSL 2. Und WSL 2 macht einen ziemlich guten Eindruck,
vor allem halt für diejenigen, die halt fest sitzen auf einem Windows, die nicht einfach
nebenbei eine Linux-VM laufen lassen können. Ich mein, ich brauch's nicht. Ich hab hier
mal eine Linux-VM laufen und die ist mir immer noch um ein Vielfaches lieber, als da mit
WSL rum zu hantieren. Aber für alle, die gezwungen sind, Windows zu verwenden und keine
VM installieren können, ist das doch gut. Wie konfigurierst du die Ressource in die
Sandbox-Plattform? Ich habe keinen plassen Schimmer, wie man das macht. Das einzige,
was ich gemacht hab, ist die Sandbox-VM anzuklicken und das war's. Wahrscheinlich kann man das
nicht konfigurieren, weil die hat ja keinerlei Settings-Menüs, die Sandbox. Sebaro fragt
gerade, kann man eigentlich auf einem Ubuntu-Server noch irgendwie einen Desktop nachinstallieren
und das per SSH-VNC-RDP sich anzeichnen lassen? Ja klar, kannst du machen. Es ist fragwürdig,
wie sinnvoll das ist, aber es geht. Du kannst zum Beispiel einen XFCE installieren und den
verwenden. Aber wozu? Ich mein, wenn du einfach nur einen Browser verwenden willst, das kannst
du über X-Forwardinger machen. Schau mal im Task Manager, was Sandbox angeht. Das stimmt
nicht, das ist nur das Frontend. Das stimmt garantiert nicht. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob man
das überhaupt sieht. Hier, V-Mem. Gigabyte, Gigabyte RAM brauchst du ungefähr. Schau
mal im Task Manager in der VM. Der Task Manager in der VM ruckelt und sagt 4 Gigabyte RAM.
Okay, vielleicht mit Swap oder so. Ach nee, der nimmt bloß so viel wie er brauche. Das
steigt wahrscheinlich. Das steigt hier wahrscheinlich dann an. Ja, guck mal, jetzt haben wir schon
1,1. Ja, das nimmt nur so viel er braucht. Sprich, wenn ich jetzt hier den Chrome aufmache
oder den Edge unter Zeug, dann geht's rauf, guckt. Also 4 Gigabyte kann er maximal fressen.
Was mehr als genug ist, also das ist okay, weil ich hab hier im System hab ich 8 Gigabyte
in der VM. Warum ist die Sandbox so lahm? Weil es VM in der VM ist, guck mal. Das Windows,
in dem ich die Sandbox laufen lasse, ist ja selbst in der VM. Das ist VM in der VM, da
musst du dich nicht wundern, dass es so langsam ist. Es ist sogar cool, dass das überhaupt
funktioniert. Und WSL ist erstaunlich schnell, muss man sagen für das, dass es VM in der
VM ist. Da kann man nix sagen. So, gibt es auch irgendwelche tollen Windows Features,
die wir hier übersehen haben. Das da nicht. PC Zurück, das ist über die Cloud, juckt
mich überhaupt nicht. Apps neu starten, das haben wir schon uns angeguckt, das haben wir
uns auch schon angeguckt, das haben wir uns auch schon angeguckt. Das haben wir uns auch
schon angeguckt. Der Suchindex birgt sich nun die Energieeinstellung. Ah, jetzt endlich,
da hab ich ja drauf gewartet. Cursorgeschwindigkeit, das haben wir uns auch schon angeguckt. Schnellsuche
im Suchmenü. Was? Schnellsuche im Suchmenü, was soll das sein? Hä? Ach, da unten? Nee,
gibt's bei mir nicht. Sag mal, Microsoft möchte uns den neuen Edge aber echt auf jeder,
überall aufs Auge drücken. Oh, das ist Big Brain. Edge in Edge starten. Habt ihr auch
schon mal Edge über Edge gestartet? Und vor allem geht's ja nicht mal. Es lädt noch nicht
mal die Seite. Als hätte jetzt der neue Edge so'n Riesenantrag, ne? Als hätte der neue
Edge so'n Riesenantrag, dass die alle sagen, oh fuck, die Seite ist überlastet, es laden
sich grad 20 Billionen Leute den neuen Edge runter. Internet geht, wie man hier sieht.
Wollen wir jetzt mal gucken, ob im Chrome die gleiche Seite funktioniert? Hehehe, witzig.
Ah, jetzt geht's ja auch. Ähm, was ist toll? WSL2 ist ziemlich gut, wenn man keine Chance
hat, ne richtige Linux VM zu verwenden. Allerdings ist WSL2 ja nicht unbedingt so wirklich Bestandteil
von diesem Update. Es geht ab diesem Update, aber Bestandteil ist es nicht. Was ist WSL?
Was ist diese Linux-Geschichte unter Windows von Microsoft? Dass das hier, guck, wo du
unter deinem Windows eine Linux laufen lassen kannst. Okay, jetzt sehen wir den neuen Edge.
Warum? Weil's geht. Eigentlich hat's keinen tieferen Sinn. Wir sind ja eigentlich schon
fast fertig gucken. So, Netzwerkeinstellung überarbeit, das haben wir uns auch schon angeschaut.
Zeit und Sprache haben wir uns auch schon angeschaut. Aus Windows Defender wird Microsoft Defender
an die Virus. Microsoft liebt es Sachen umzubenennen, an die sich die Leute gewöhnt haben. Microsoft
steht da einfach drauf, Sachen umzubenennen. Das Gleiche mit Office 365, dass Microsoft
365 wird. Von diesem ganzen Debakel mit.NET 5, wie sie jetzt was nennen, muss ich ja gar
nicht anfangen. Und das Allerschlimmste, woran ich noch, wo ich ihnen noch jahrelange böse
sein werde, ist, dass sie Xbox Scarlet gekillt haben und jetzt Xbox Series X nennen. Der
schlechteste Konsolenname aller Zeiten, den sich keine Sau merken kann. Xbox Scarlet,
so ein schöner Name. Und was macht man? Xbox Series X. Ich mein, was kann man sich besser
merken? Xbox Scarlet oder Xbox Series X? Continue. Ja, Google macht das genau, Google macht das
anders. Google kündigt was Neues mit viel Tamtam an und dann supporten sie es nicht
und stellen es ein. Da gibt's sie gekillt bei Google. Mal gucken, was in letztens wieder
dazugekommen ist. Stadia geht jetzt ja voll ab, Leute. Habt ihr schon mitgekriegt, wie
geil Stadia abgeht? Was genau macht der neue Edge Browser da? Welcome to Edge. What? Ja,
mach einfach. Continue without. Es lohnt sich auch. Microsoft Edge, welcome microsoft.com.
Sehr schöne Seite. So, und das ist jetzt der Chromium Edge. Microsoft Edge für iOS und
Yes. Ich hab da nicht mal ein Telefonnummer. Leaked, Leute. Leaked. Kekwe leaked. Schau
wieder. Max Handy leaked. Okay, was ist das letzte, was Google mal wieder gekillt hat?
AngularJS ist doch nicht gekillt. Ach, die Einser oder die alte Version? Weil Angular
selbst gibt's doch noch. Angular 2 Plus lebt noch, genau. Das alte Angular, das was viele
Leute gut fanden. App Maker, kenne ich nicht. Google Cloud Print kenne ich auch nicht.
Google Hangouts ist weg? Echt? Ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, wie auf YouTube die Leute
teilweise ihre Videos über Hangout aufgenommen haben. Wirklich gut war Google Hangout noch
nie. Hire by Google kenne ich nicht. Shoelace, was? Aber ich, ich weiß überhaupt nicht,
überhaupt nicht, was das ist. Neighborly kenne ich auch nicht. Fabric kenne ich auch
nicht. Der Material Seam Editor ist tot, okay. Hab ich noch nie verwendet. Google Station
Tutor, ich kenne den ganzen Kram nicht. Google Correlate, Google Translator Tutor, das ist
doof, dass es das nicht mehr gibt. Man konnte ja Webseiten übersetzen lassen, in Google
ohne irgendwie Browser Plugin, das geht jetzt nicht mehr. Der Google Url Shotner, das verstehe
ich bis heute nicht, warum sie das eingestellt haben. Google hat fast alles, was man so braucht
in der Richtung, aber einen Url Shotner haben sie nicht. Das verstehe ich bis heute nicht,
warum der Google Url Shotner eingestellt wurde. PC Lustig sagt, so ein Google Hangout nimmt
zwar YouTube immer noch zum Streamen ohne Encoder Software. Den Satz habe ich nicht verstanden.
Okay, das haben wir uns schon angeguckt, haben wir uns auch angeguckt. Ah, das ist der offizielle
Microsoft Blogpost, was die Neues haben. Notepad News, oh Leute, jetzt erfahren wir endlich,
was es in Notepad Neues gibt. Small but mighty improvements in Notepad. Wrap around, find
and replace. Ah, exzellent. Oh, was geht denn heute ab, meine Güte, habt ihr, jetzt mal,
Leute, habt ihr heute Geld gekriegt oder so? Kam euch das Gehalt an? Wurden Überstunden
ausbezahlen, gab es irgendeinen Bonus? Oder habt ihr einfach nur zu viel Geld? Aber trotzdem,
Dankeschön für die Subs. Ja, was haben wir, wen haben wir da am Start? Da tagen sie
auch schon wieder. Also bald, bald platzt der Copier. Und zwar, wen haben wir denn da?
Ja, schonmal Dankeschön. Super, also, ich weiß gar nicht, was ich sagen soll. So viele
Subscribers. Ähm. Wer hat was gekriegt? Tazen hat was gekriegt, Gamer995D, JSW77, Vorti,
Hofer Didi, Iplayfairfair12, KriegsG, ScheiterhaufenausMoney. Das ist wirklich mal ein guter Name.
Manu1004, SurfJelly kriegt ein Abo, der hat es verdient, der ist schon lange am Start. Der Name, der sagt mir was.
TotalDisarray, NoLimitXO, PassiP, MondEverest, den hab ich auch schonmal irgendwo gesehen,
in den letzten Tagen. SchriebsHD, Konrad spielt D-Mark, was? D-Mark, 3 Meter? Ah ja. LeoLollTV und DartObson, Stufe 1.
MassivePoggers, Dankeschön für die ganzen Subs. Jetzt reicht es aber mal. Alter Leute, jetzt kommt der Patrick.
Jetzt übertreibt es doch mal nicht so. Übertreibt es doch mal nicht so. Jetzt muss ich ja demnächst wieder
Steuererklärungen machen. Was soll das? Kann ich die Steuererklärungen nicht mehr dodgen?
Der Patrick verschenkt nochmal 10 Stufe 1 Abos. Hat jetzt insgesamt 42 verstellen. Verschenkt.
Und wer kriegt jetzt welche? Raytek96, SilencePain. Der ist ja schon lange am Start. Der hat es auf jeden Fall verdient.
Der Kelmo ist auch noch eine Weile am Start. Der hat es auch mehr als verdient. Ich kenne ja so die üblichen Verdächtigen mit der Zeit.
SideLane, Timo, MatthewBrandt, BeeWater, MyFriend, xD. Boah, pp ist richtiger pp gerade aber irgendwie.
Aber, äh, jeder wie er will. MrSultanois, Karniel10, Zebellum. Dankeschön für die ganzen Subs heute. Wahnsinn.
NoScope. Der NoScope Max abonniert. Excellent. Ähm, TheHeroMaster. Twitch Prime, Dankeschön. Nice up.
Kupferman abonniert auch sieben Monate schon am Start. Poggers. Und der Patrick hat noch ein Abo verschenkt und zwar an den PC Lustig.
Der ist auch schon eine Weile am Start. Der hat es auf jeden Fall verdient.
JokeGamingOffie. Sechs Monate. Nice. Dem kann ich nur zustimmen. Extrem nice und extrem MassifyIQ. Wahnsinn. Super.
Tja. Jetzt muss ich ja langsam echt wieder Steuern bezahlen. Also richtig viel.
Alter, Leute. Ist gut jetzt. Ich geh gleich off. Ich geh off, wenn ihr nicht aufhört. Hört auf mir so die Kohle in den Arsch zu schieben.
Soll ich, was soll ich denn dazu noch sagen? Das ist doch nicht normal.
Ah. Neues PC-Bild. Halt dich eigentlich nicht vor. Wen haben wir denn noch mal am Start hier? Der.
Einmal haben wir den BrinDom. Den hab ich nicht gesehen. Zwei Monate. Und ein verschenkter Tanzer. Nochmal. Zehn Stufe eins Abos.
AndiCommunity hat schon 94 Stück. Der hört gar nicht mehr auf. Borgas.
IceNaps. OifMiner. Der ist da. OifMiner ist auch schon öfters am Start. Den hab ich auch schon gesehen.
Whiskey. Motski. Gurke97a. Jsp64. TheOsaru. Clani. Clani ist auch schon öfters da gewesen. Den hab ich auch schon öfters mal gesehen.
Demon. Hin. Demon. Ha. Linter. Ok. Was auch immer. Was uns abgeschenkt bekommen.
Und Zoxym kriegt auch noch Stufe eins da. Meine Güte. Meine Güte. Der ist aber voll übertrieben. Voll übertrieben.
Mach halt ein paar Spenden. Ich hab schon gespendet letztens. Hey. Ich hab immerhin. Ich hab immerhin.
Katzenhilfe. Ja. Ich hab letztens gespendet. An.
Andi hier. Und die hams. Irgendwas. Karlsruhe hieß das. Ja.
Letztens war es gespendet hier. Andi. Katzenhilfe. Karlsruhe. Die hams echt verdient laut Homepage.
Ich hab den Tweet gesehen. Hab den gleich mal ein bisschen Kohle dagelassen. Weil.
Generell. Ich bin jemand. Ich spende viel lieber für irgendein Tierheim oder sonst was.
Als für humanitäre Zwecke. Kann man jetzt sagen. Wie kann. Ich weiß nicht. Irgendwie.
Sind mir Katzen lieber als Menschen. Kann ja jeder spenden was er will.
Jetzt weiß ich gar nicht wo ich aufgehört hab hier. Geht ja gerade richtig ab.
Danke schön. Und der Patrick schenkt noch mehr ab. Sonst war er ein Tantra Lehrer.
Exzellent. Und. An den Saboteur. Der Saboteur. Den hab ich auch schon ein paar Mal hier gesehen.
Ich glaube ich hab mittlerweile. Wenn ich. Ich hab bestimmt mittlerweile 25 Emote Slots oder so.
Ich hab mittlerweile bestimmt 25. Ich guck mal kurz wie viele Emote Slots ich hab. Wartet mal.
Oh sieht man das Creator Dashboard Kanal. Das ist immer ein bisschen versteckt. Das ist immer ein bisschen versteckt. Ich guck mal kurz.
Ich guck mal kurz nach wie viele Emote Slots ich mittlerweile hab.
Da muss man immer in die Partner Settings. Ich find mich unglaublich schlecht zurecht.
In diesem Settings. Settings von Twitch. Genau.
Also wir haben. Hier war es Präferenzen. Inhalt. Partner. Genau Partner.
Emotes. Ok also ich zähle mal. Also 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 haben wir.
Und. Davon sind 4 belegt. Das heißt 16 Emote Slots hab ich noch frei.
So langsam muss ich den Pfeifer Inder aber echt aber auftragen neue Emotes zu machen.
Ja 4 von 20 Emotes. Ich geh echt zum Pfeifer Inder. Nee ich geh nicht zum Pfeifer Inder.
Ich frag auf. Ich frag auf Twitch. Was ist ein gutes Budget? Was ist ein gutes Budget?
Was mein ihr? Wenn ich auf Twitter gehe und sag. Ja ich weiß die Sub-Notification läuft immer noch. Die kommt nicht hinterher.
Was meint ihr ist ein gutes Budget? Wenn ich auf Twitter gehe und sag ich brauch ein paar Emotes. Aktuelles Budget.
Sagen wir mal so 200 Euro. Und dann einfach mal gucke wer da am Start ist und was machen will.
Weil wie gesagt umsonst lasse ich die Leute natürlich nichts machen.
Aber mal testweise will ich auch nicht so viel ausgeben weil ich will erstmal gucken dass man mit den Leuten auch ordentlich arbeiten kann.
Weil ich hab keinen Bock dass ich mir beispielsweise jetzt 5 Emotes kaufe bei einem.
Aber das niemand ist mit dem man irgendwie ordentlich zusammenarbeiten kann. Also sprich es kann ja durchaus sein.
Dass ich mal in Zukunft dann ein bisschen was brauche. Was keine Ahnung.
Das eine Emote muss ein bisschen angepasst werden. Oder vielleicht gefällt es mir ein halbes Jahr später nicht.
Der muss das natürlich nie umsonst machen. Aber ich brauch dann auch irgendein mit dem man da auch langfristig mal zusammenarbeiten kann.
Montana Black hat glaube ich 50 Euro pro Emote geboten. Ja ich finde das gar nicht so schlecht.
Also das kommt natürlich auf die Qualität an. Und was da noch alles dabei ist.
Also ein paar Revisions müssen da auf jeden Fall dabei sein. Und auch ein bisschen Support quasi.
Weil ich mein je nachdem wie einfach das Emote ist. Wenn 50 Emote für ein kleines Pixel Emote sind was du in 2 Minuten zusammengezimmert hast.
Dann lohnt sich das nicht. Wenn es natürlich was ist was mich voll überzeugt. Dann ist es angemessen.
Ja am liebsten hätte ich auch alles von einem. Ich hätte wirklich am liebsten alles von einem.
Das die Sache ist die ich hab ganz gute Ideen wir haben ja auch schon im Stream gesammelt.
Was für Emotes man machen kann.
Ich mein ich hab mir den Emote-Name aufgeschrieben und ein bisschen was was man machen könnte.
Aber aus dieser Idee was zu bauen was mich überzeugt.
Dass ich quasi mir das angucke und sage ja das ist gut. Das kommt sehr selten vor.
Und ich hab meistens ein bisschen was dann rumzumeckern.
Aber ich sehe relativ schnell ob da was rauskommt was ich am Ende verwenden kann.
Echt man kann mit Emoterstellung Geld verdienen. Klar. Natürlich.
Ich mein wo ist der Unterschied ob du jetzt irgendwelche Bilder machst.
Lass das mal für irgendeinen Magazin sein oder für Webseiten oder Twitch Emotes.
Twitch Designs, Twitch Emotes. Sonst was. Wenn du das gut kannst. Klar.
Hat man ja auch zurecht Geld für verdient. Warum sollte das jemand umsonst machen.
Ja zum Beispiel für MonkaS Smoke würde ich jetzt keine 50 Euro bezahlen.
Aber nix gegen Serious Max hat das glaube ich gemacht.
Nix gegen MonkaS Smoke ja. Aber die künstlerische Tiefe hält sich ja schon in Grenzen.
Auch wenn es ein ziemlich gutes Emote ist muss man ja mal sagen.
Das Bahn Emote. Das Bahn Emote hätte tatsächlich was verdient ja.
Vor allem vor allem wie pock hier die die die Streifen drüber gemalt sind ja.
Also für beide zusammen vielleicht 5 Euro.
Was mir halt vorschwebt bei Emotes ist.
Und das ist halt schwierig alles alles so ein bisschen zu kombinieren.
Erstens natürlich Sachen die gut passen. Zum Beispiel muss auf jeden Fall irgend so ein Leak Emote sein ja.
Weil ich leake ja angeblich laufend irgendwas.
Ja was wollte ich jetzt sagen.
Genau also wie gesagt zum Beispiel zum Beispiel zum Beispiel ein Leak Emote.
Aber wo wollte ich jetzt drauf raus.
Ich hab's vergessen. C++ Emote genau so ein Ding.
Genau und die Dinger müssen halt irgendwie schon in gewisser Weise einzigartig sein.
Also damit meine ich nicht dass nur ich die Emotes habe.
Aber die sollten auch die sollten auch ein bisschen rausstechen.
Mal zum Beispiel mal ein Beispiel zu bringen was ich meine ist.
Als Overwatch neu war und Moon Moon angefangen hat zu streamen.
Ich gucke ihn by the way nicht ja.
Aber die Moon Moon Emotes kennt man auf ganz Twitch.
Der war einer der ersten der mit diesen Overwatch Cute Emotes angefangen hat.
Und finde ich hat immer noch mit die besten.
Und das heißt nicht dass ich sowas haben will wie er hat.
Weil das gibt es ja schon.
Sondern es muss auch ein bisschen was gewisses einzigartiges haben.
Das Barney Emote mit animiertem Scheibenwischer.
Oh ja das wäre das wäre exzellent.
Das wäre richtig Pock.
Wenn man MonkaDB hätten mit animiertem Scheibenwischer.
Das Max FPS Reveal Mod.
Ja das brauchen wir auf jeden Fall.
League Reveal was auch immer.
Max du Tant.
Ich gehe mal davon aus dass du einfach Max heißt.
Ich würde auch sagen also die meisten Streamer.
Wenn sie anfangen versuchen sich wahrscheinlich an Emotes.
Aber werden daran scheitern.
Und manche streamen jahrelang und haben ihre selbstgemachten Crap Emotes weiter drinnen.
Wenn sie natürlich erfolgreich streamen und der Content überzeugt ist das jetzt nicht so wild.
Das ist ja eh Voraussetzung im Endeffekt.
Aber die meisten sollten lieber jemand dran lassen der es kann.
Brauche ich ja auch noch Subbatches Leute.
Ich brauche auch noch Subbatches.
Ich brauche auch noch Subbatches Leute.
Oh das wird teuer.
Weg zum Goldkeks genau.
Ich brauche Emotes und Subbatches.
Und am schlimmsten ist das sollte alles irgendwie einheitlich sein.
Gutes Beispiel für gute Emote ist auch Dance Gaming.
Dance Gaming hat auch immer gute Emotes aber der übertreibt es total.
Der übertreibt es wirklich.
Der macht ja teilweise eigene Emotes pro Let's Play.
Also ich glaube nicht dass ich quasi wenn ich sage ach heute Abend könnte ich mal einen Stream machen zum Thema XY.
Dann die passenden Emotes dafür hochlade.
Der Patrick hat schon wieder sein Abo verschenkt und zwar an.
Absolute Dankeschön.
Aber hört jetzt auf Leute ich gehe jetzt eh gleich off.
Für heute ist gut ja.
Dance Gaming hat mehr oder weniger fest jemand angestellt.
Oh Gott Leute jetzt hört mal auf heute.
Ist gut.
Es ist genug.
Hebt euch was auf fürs nächste Mal.
Ich bin jetzt wie gesagt ich bin jetzt eh gleich off.
Es lohnt sich jetzt gar nicht mehr nochmal drauf zu drücken.
Tänzer Dankeschön sechs Subscriptions gibts noch.
10 kriegt eins Max du Tant.
Ziffy Gaming Ghost Rider.
Trion 93 und der Strafraum Prediger.
Keycaps in unterschiedlichen Farben.
Bei Subbatches bin ich mir wirklich unsicher.
Da bin ich aber keine Ahnung was ich machen will.
Der Chat dem ist der Kopf schon geplatzt heute.
Subschätzen machen wir heute nicht.
Es haben so viele Leute heute Subs gekriegt.
Es ist wahrscheinlich kaum noch einer nicht Sub im Chat.
Heute dabei ist wahrscheinlich kaum einer unsubbt.
OMG jetzt Mo.
Dann kriegst du das nächste Mal einen.
Herz 93 du bist Sub siehste.
Man müsste ein IQ Logo machen um den IQ Pro Submonat darzustellen.
Das wäre cool man bräuchte quasi so einen Big Brain der immer größer wird irgendwie.
Oder immer Big Brainiger.
Oder der Keks bekommt ein Gehirn.
Auch eine Möglichkeit ja.
So der Keks der ein Gehirn bekommt finde ich eine ganz gute Idee.
Es ist 22.10 Uhr ich gehe jetzt pennen.
Vielleicht sehen wir uns morgen.
Es kann aber auch sein dass ich morgen eine Runde Warthorn spiele.
Allerdings nicht im Stream.
Langsam komme ich halbwegs rein.
Ich habe schon ein paar Wins am Start.
KD wird auch immer besser.
OP Klassen sind am Start.
Ich weiß nicht ob ich das streame eher nicht.
Spätestens.
Wahrscheinlich Samstag Sonntag so in dem Dreh.
Spätestens Sonntag morgens da bin ich eh wieder am Start.
Das ist ja schon Standard.
Und dann gucken wir mal.
Also macht es gut.
Bis morgen übermorgen so in dem Dreh.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.